AND CALLED THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING OUR VICE CHAIR ANY
MOMENT, SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS. UM.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT
LONG SCRIPT ANYMORE. WE'VE
CHANGED A LITTLE BIT OF OUR OF
OUR WAY OF OPERATING IN THE NEW
YEAR. SO UM, BUT I WILL STILL
SAY FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR COURT
REPORTER TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY AND IF YOU SEE HER YOU
KNOW, KIND OF LOOKING AT YOU TO
SLOW DOWN OR REPEAT WILL JUST
HELP MAKE THAT HAPPEN BECAUSE WE
ARE WE ARE KEEPING A RECORD OF
TRANSCRIPT SO. I WILL GO AHEAD
AT THIS POINT AND ASK OUR
SECRETARY TO PLEASE ESTABLISHED
A QUORUM AND TO CALL THE ROLL.
LAIRD HERE SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALL EQUIVALENCE HERE. WILK
PRESENT PRESENT GROVE GROVE.
HERE. ATKINS HERE. ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU, MADAM SECRETARY. AND
FOR THE RECORD, I WILL SAY WE
HAVE SENATOR WILK JOINING US
TODAY AS A REPLACEMENT FOR
SENATOR AKO BOGUE, WHO WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY. HE HAS
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE,
SO WE'LL GO FORWARD WITHOUT
MISSING A BEAT. I AM GOING TO
SEE IF WE CAN BEFORE WE CALL THE
FIRST, UM CONTRARY TO SEE IF WE
CAN DISPENSE WITH SOME BUSINESS.
I UNDERSTAND ON ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE MAY WANT
TO DO A SEPARATE VOTE ON THAT.
OKAY I WOULD ASK FOR A MOTION TO
APPROVE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES.
ITEMS TO SEE IRA LIT TO THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER CREDENTIAL
E. I WOULD SO MOVE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY,
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
LAIRD I SMALL LIQUID EQUIVALENCY
. WILK WILK? AYE GROVE GROVE,
NOT VOTING. ATKINS 40 00. I
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ON ITEM TWO D
. CARL CHIP ROBERTSON J. D AS A
MEMBER OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF LAW. SAN
FRANCISCO. THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MOVED AND MADAM CHAIR
I KNOW HIM, AND I NEVER KNEW
WHAT HIS FIRST NAME IS. SO I'M
VERY GRATEFUL THAT IT'S HERE ON
THE AGENDA. I'M GOING TO TEASE
HIM THE NEXT TIME I TALK TO HIM.
WELL I'M GONNA HAVE SENATOR WILK
. NO YOU WERE FIRST SENATOR WILK
MADE THE MOTION NOTED, FOR THE
RECORD THAT YOU NOW KNOW HIS
FIRST NAME IS CARL. WE DID THAT.
SO YOU WOULD KNOW THIS, SENATOR
LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY, WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? LAYERED
PARADISE SMALLWOOD SERVICE TO
SAY WILK GROVE GROVE. I ATKINS
ATKINS I 5 TO 5 TO 0. WONDERFUL
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM THREE BILL REFERRALS. THANK
YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR CALLED THE
ROLE LAYERED SMALL REQUEST THIS
SERVICE I WILK GROVE GROVE. I
ATKINS 5 TO 5 TO 0. THANK YOU. I
AM FOR THIS IS COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS. THIS WOULD BE TO
REMOVE SENATOR WAHABI AND
MYSELF. AS MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON RULES REDUCING THE
COMMITTEE SENATE MEMBERSHIP FROM
16 TO 14. THIS WOULD ALIGN US
WITH THE ASSEMBLY'S ACTION JUST
FOR THE PUBLIC BENEFIT, I WOULD
ASK FOR A MOTION. THANK YOU,
MADAM. VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
LAYERED SMALL EQUIVALENT TO SAY
WILK GROVE. I ATKINS I FIVE TO
05 TO ZERO. THANK YOU. ITEM FIVE
WOULD BE OUR SESSIONS SCHEDULE
FOR 2024 TO ADOPT. MOVE THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT FOR REVOTE. YES
SENATOR WILK SO EXCITED THAT
WE'RE BREAKING BEFORE JULY 4TH
BECAUSE I HATE COMING UP HERE
THAN FLYING HOME BECAUSE THAT'S
A WORKDAY FOR REPUBLICANS. WORK
ALL DAY AND ALL NIGHT AND THEY
HAVE TO COME BACK UP FOR THE
NEXT DAY. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
SCHEDULE THIS YEAR. VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. I'M CHANGING MY
POSITION ON THANK YOU. OBVIOUSLY
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF A NEW YEAR
. WE HAVE SOME VERY HAPPY AND
ENLIGHTENED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT IS A WORKDAY FOR
DEMOCRATS AS WELL. AND WITH THAT
, I FORGET WHO MADE THE MOTION.
THANK YOU, MADAM SECRETARY.
POLICE. CALL THE ROLL, LAIRD. I
SERVICE CRITICIZED WILK. AYE
GROVE GROVE. I ATKINS I 5 TO 5
TO 0. THANK YOU. AND, UH, LAST,
CERTAINLY, BUT NOT LEAST, FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS. WE HAVE ITEMS
67 AND EIGHT. UM WHICH MY
COLLEAGUES CAN READ. IT'S A LOT
TO, UH, GO THROUGH, BUT EMOTION.
AND WE CAN WE TAKE ALL THREE
TOGETHER, 67 AND EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK, UM
AND GO CALL THE ROLE. I WOULD I,
SMALLWOOD KRAVIS, ALL
EQUIVALENCY WILK, GROVE GROVE. I
ATKINS I 5 TO 0. THANK YOU. 5 TO
0. SO THANK YOU, EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WITH THAT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE HAVE TWO
WILL GO RIGHT TO ITEM A AND THEN
AND LET ME WELCOME UP. LINDSEY
SIN, THE SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. WELCOME
AND AS YOU'RE COMING UP, I WILL,
UH, OFFER YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO THAT IS WITH YOU AND
THEN MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WELCOME.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM PRO TIM ATKINS,
VICE CHAIR GROVE. AMNESTY
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE. I GUESS I'LL BEGIN BY
SAYING JUST TO COMMENT OFF OF
SENATOR WILKES COMMENT ABOUT THE
FOURTH OF JULY BECAUSE I
TYPICALLY WORK IN VETERANS
AFFAIRS ON MEMORIAL DAY AND
VETERANS DAY. I DO MY BEST TO
TRY AND TAKE OFF INDEPENDENCE
DAY. SO UM, I'M ABSOLUTELY
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY. I AM
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE FOR THE
POSITION OF SECRETARY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. I ALSO HAVE
THE DISTINCTION OF BEING THE
FIRST WOMAN APPOINTED AS
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY TO SHARE MY VISION AS WELL
AS ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE TIME
THAT YOU HAVE ALREADY TAKEN WITH
ME THAT YOUR STAFF HAVE TAKEN
WITH ME IN PREPARATION FOR THIS
CONFIRMATION HEARING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FIRST I'D LIKE TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME AND ABOUT
WHY I SIT BEFORE YOU TODAY
SERVING VETERANS IS NOT JUST A
CAREER. FOR ME. IT'S ALSO A
PASSION AND A CALLING AS YOU
ALREADY ARE AWARE, MOST LIKELY I
SERVED EIGHT YEARS ON ACTIVE
DUTY IN THE UNITED STATES. NAVY
GO NAVY. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAVEL THE WORLD AND WORK
WITH EACH BRANCH OF OUR
MILITARY. I ALSO MADE LASTING
FRIENDSHIPS WITH MANY OF THE
PEOPLE WITH WHOM I SERVED. I
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS TO SERVE
THIS COUNTRY IN UNIFORM. AND
LIKE MANY OF MY FELLOW VETERANS,
I'VE ALSO EXPERIENCED THE
CHALLENGES OF TRANSITIONING FROM
THE MILITARY AND REBUILDING MY
CIVILIAN LIFE. LIKEWISE I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE THAT OUR
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM BRING
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND,
MOST IMPORTANTLY, BACK HERE TO
CALIFORNIA. WHEN I WAS A NEWLY
MINTED CIVILIAN, I BEGAN THE
PROCESS OF BUILDING A NEW LIFE
FOR MYSELF, AND AFTER COMPLETING
MY BACHELOR'S DEGREE, I STARTED
WORKING WITH VETERANS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. THAT'S WHEN I KNEW
THAT I WANTED TO MAKE THIS A
PERMANENT JOB AND CAREER PATH
FOR ME. SO FOR THE PAST 12 YEARS
, I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK IN VARIOUS APPOINTED
POSITIONS AT CAL VET, INCLUDING
AS DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR WOMEN
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND AS DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR COMMUNICATIONS. I
LOVE WORKING IN STATE GOVERNMENT
, AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT MY
PASSION MY EXPERIENCES MY
LEADERSHIP STYLE AND EAGERNESS
TO LEARN WILL SET US UP FOR
CONTINUED SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE.
BUT I DON'T DO THIS WORK ALONE.
AND I'M GRATEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC
THAT SO MANY OF OUR DEDICATED
CALVET EMPLOYEES AND MY TALENTED
LEADERSHIP TEAM WILL MAKE THIS
NEXT PHASE OF OUR DEPARTMENT, A
PERIOD OF SUCCESSFUL GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL. SO IN
CLOSING. I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH PAST AND PRESENT
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO THIS
WORK. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
FAMILY. MOST SPECIFICALLY MY
HUSBAND, MATT, MY TWO CHILDREN.
MAXWELL WHO IS NINE AND CHARLIE,
WHO IS SEVEN FOR THEIR CONTINUED
LOVE AND SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE OF ME AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I AM GOING
TO START WITH OUR VICE CHAIR.
THE ONE MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT ACTUALLY HAS SERVED IN THE
MILITARY. SO MADAM VICE CHAIR.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. MADAM PRO
TIM. THANK YOU. I REALLY ENJOYED
OUR TIME THAT WE SPENT TOGETHER.
I REALLY DO ADMIRE YOU AND WHAT
YOU'VE DONE. YOU'VE SERVED IN
OUR UNITED STATES MILITARY PUT
ON A UNIFORM AND THEN NOW YOU'RE
STILL SERVING OUR VETERANS
ACROSS THE STATE. I LOVE YOUR
HEART AND PASSION FOR THE
VETERANS THAT ARE IN OUR STATE.
I ASKED. OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE THE
SECRETARY. BUT UM, I ASKED YOU A
KIND OF NOT A SILLY QUESTION.
BUT IF YOU WERE QUEEN FOR THE
DAY BECAUSE I REALIZED THAT
THERE IS A PROCESS YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW NOW, BUT IF YOU WERE
QUEEN FOR THE DAY, WHAT IS THE
ONE THING THAT YOU WOULD TAKE
CARE OF? FOR OUR VETERANS THAT
SEEMS TO HAUNT US. I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
I REALLY APPRECIATED OUR TIME
TOGETHER AS WELL. AND I'LL SHARE
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. WHAT? WHAT
I MENTIONED TO SENATOR GROVE WAS
THAT I THINK THE TOP TWO ISSUES
WE'RE FACING DEALING WITH OUR
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE
ISSUES OF HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH. AND TO THAT END, I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR SHARES THOSE TWO
GOALS AS WELL. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO WORK HARD ON IN
THIS DEPARTMENT. TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN ADDRESS. WE'VE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS WITH THINGS LIKE OUR
VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM,
WHICH HAS BUILT 3200 UNITS OVER
THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS,
AWARDING 94 DEVELOPMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO HOUSE VETERANS AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. WE ALSO
NOW HAVE THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS
HEALTH INITIATIVE, WHICH IS A
$50 MILLION INITIATIVE TO LOOK
AT THE ISSUE OF VETERAN SUICIDE
AND MENTAL HEALTH FOR VETERANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HERE.
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A REALLY
TALENTED TEAM AROUND ME, AND I
KNOW THAT THESE ARE TOP OF MIND
GOALS TO THEM, TOO. SO I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE
ON SOME OF THESE WISH LIST ITEMS
THAT I HAVE. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'M JUST GOING
TO TAKE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND SCORE BIG POINTS
HERE BY THINKING MY SWEET FRIEND
TINA PHILLIPS FOR SERVING THE
UNITED STATES NAVY AS WELL. AND
THEN I'M GOING TO TURN IT BACK
OVER TO THE MADAM PRO TIM AND
SHE CAN PASS IT ON TO SOMEONE
ELSE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU,
MA'AM. THANK YOU, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. SHE ALWAYS ONE UPS ME
WITH MY TWIN SISTER, TINA
PHILLIPS. AND IN FACT, I THINK
MY TWIN SISTER TINA, CALLS MADAM
VICE CHAIR MORE OFTEN THAN SHE
CALLS ME. SO THANK YOU. IT'S A
VETERAN THING. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT, AND I'M SURE MY SISTER IS
NOT WATCHING US, BUT I WILL LET
HER KNOW. LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS TO
CONTINUE THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, MADAM PRO
TEM. AND SO I'LL THROW IN MY
VETERAN MY MOTHER WHO WAS A NAVY
NURSE, SO IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE WONDERFUL WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP IN OUR ARMED FORCES
AND NOW, POTENTIALLY TAKING THE
HELM OF OUR VETERAN AFFAIRS. I
WANTED TO ALSO SAY IT WAS
WONDERFUL TO MEET WITH YOU AND
TO JUST HEAR YOUR PASSION BUT
ALSO YOUR GRASP ON SO MANY OF
THE DETAILS OF THE WORK THAT'S
MOVING FORWARD AND REALLY
EXCITING. TO HEAR ALL OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING THERE. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STRUCK ME WAS OUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING, AND I WONDER IF YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
PARTICULARLY ABOUT THE ROLE OF
WOMEN SURE, IN OUR IN OUR RANKS
AND ALSO POTENTIALLY IN TERMS OF
OUR VETERAN AFFAIRS, HOW
IMPORTANT WOMEN ARE GOING TO BE
TO THE SERVICES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR THAT
QUESTION, SENATOR I REALLY
APPRECIATED OUR TIME TOGETHER. I
WAS VERY EXCITED TO LEARN ABOUT
YOUR MOTHER'S SERVICE. THAT'S
WONDERFUL, AND HAVING SERVED AS
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY PREVIOUSLY
FOR WOMEN VETERANS AFFAIRS. THIS
IS, OF COURSE, A PERSONAL
PASSION OF MINE. IN ADDITION TO
SOMETHING OUR DEPARTMENT LOOKS
AT VERY SERIOUSLY, SO, YES, THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AMONG OUR VETERANS
ARE CHANGING. WE KNOW THAT OUR
NUMBER OF VETERANS IN THE STATE
WILL CONTINUE TO REDUCE AS WE
MOVE FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY
FROM FROM SPECIFIC CONFLICTS
THAT WE FACED, BUT AS AS THOSE
NUMBERS REDUCE AND TIME GOES ON,
OUR VETERAN PROFILES ARE ALSO
CHANGING, SO THE MILITARY IS
BECOMING MORE FEMALE. MORE
DIVERSE. UM AS WELL AS A LITTLE
BIT YOUNGER AS OUR VETERAN
COHORT. SO WHEN FOLKS ARE COMING
OUT OF THE MILITARY, WE'RE
SEEING MORE WOMEN COMING OUT OF
THE MILITARY. WE'RE ALSO SEEING
AH, MUCH MORE DIVERSE POPULATION
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE SERVED,
INCLUDING A YOUNGER POPULATION.
IT'S SKEWING YOUNGER, SO WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
CHALLENGES AND NEW WAYS THAT WE
NEED TO ADAPT IN SERVING THAT
POPULATION, AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT OUR DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON FOR SOME TIME. IN
FACT, I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
BOTH OUR DIVISIONS THAT FOCUS ON
UNDERREPRESENTED VETERANS AS
WELL AS WOMEN VETERANS HAVE
GROWN OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
WE'VE ADDED STAFF AND MANAGERS
TO THOSE POSITION. THANKS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THANKS TO
THE WORK OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE
RUNNING THOSE DIVISIONS
CURRENTLY SO I THINK THAT NOW
THAT WE HAVE ADDITIONAL STAFF,
AND WE HAVE CONTINUED PROGRAMS
THAT THAT WE WILL INTERACT WITH
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE OVERLAY
THE LENS OF THE SPECIFIC
CHALLENGES THAT ARE CHANGING
VETERANS ARE FACING WE'RE WELL
POSITIONED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD AND THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE INCORPORATING THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND CHALLENGES IN
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE ROLL OUT
WONDERFUL, AND I WAS REALLY
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT POTENTIAL
FOCUS ON WOMEN AND CAREERS AND
SURE, WHAT ARE THE SERVICES THAT
ARE WOMEN VETERANS WILL NEED AS
THEY ENTER THE WORKFORCE. MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE
POINT THAT YOU RAISED EARLIER AS
PRIORITY AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH
HOUSING, AND WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THIS. UM NOT ONLY IS
MY MOTHER A VETERAN, BUT I ALSO
HAVE COUSINS AND UNCLES AND
OTHERS WHO ARE STILL ACTIVE DUTY
AND HAD BEEN GIVEN SOME SOME
CONCERNING NEWS IN TERMS OF
ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS, THOSE WHO
ARE BEING STATIONED HERE IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA, UM,
FINDING IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
FIND HOUSING AND IN FACT, SOME
OF THEM EVEN SLEEPING IN THEIR
CARS, BECAUSE EITHER THEIR
ALLOCATIONS ARE NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE
RENTS EM AND OR THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO JUST FIND THE HOUSING
THAT THEY NEED A THIRD OF THE
NATION'S ON HOUSED VETERANS.
UNFORTUNATELY, LIVE IN THIS
STATE, AND YOU KNOW PART OF
THIS. I KNOW YOU MENTIONED.
WE'RE CHANGING. WE'RE BUILDING
HOUSING. BUT I ALSO WONDER HOW
DOES CALVIN IT'S REALLY THINK
ABOUT THE WAY OF GETTING
INFORMATION OUT TO VETERANS. HOW
DO YOU ALSO WORK WITH YOUR
ACTIVE DUTY? UM FACILITIES AWARE
WHERE ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS ARE
HOUSED. WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH VETERANS AFFAIRS? AND, YOU
KNOW, IS THERE A WAY TO THAT WE
CAN BE HELPFUL AND HELPING TO
INCREASE THE WAYS IN WHICH
VETERANS GET INFORMATION ABOUT
HOUSING. WHETHER THERE, UM YOU
KNOW, AND I KNOW ACTIVE DUTY IS
NOT IN YOUR WHEELHOUSE, BUT IN
TERMS OF THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
CAN HELP TO BETTER SHARE
INFORMATION SO THAT THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE MAKING THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE WHEN THEY COME TO OUR
GREAT STATE HAVE HAVE A PLACE TO
LIVE, SO I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
ABSOLUTELY. I WOULD SAY OUR
DEPARTMENT'S GONE THROUGH
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH OVER THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS OR SO. ONE AREA
WHERE WE'VE GROWN IS WITHIN OUR
VETERANS SERVICES DIVISION AND
BRINGING ON SOME PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
EDUCATING NEAR VETERANS. SO
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS AS
WELL AS VETERANS OF ALL ERAS,
AND THAT'S OUR CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN, I WOULD
SAY GROUNDBREAKING IN SOME OF
THE WAYS THAT IT'S REACHING OUT
TO MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS WHO
ARE ABOUT TO BECOME VETERANS AND
THEN LOOKING FOR THOSE MOMENTS
THAT MATTER IN A VETERAN'S LIFE
AND LAYING OUT WHAT WE SEE AS
REALLY THE VETERAN LIFECYCLE AND
EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE TO
INTERACT WITH OUR FOLKS AT ANY
STAGE OF THEIR LIVES TO INTERACT
WITH THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AT ANY
STAGE OF OUR LIVES. SO SINCE CAL
TAPS INCEPTION WE HAVE REACHED
OVER 27,000 MILITARY, MILITARY
MEMBERS, VETERANS OR FAMILY
MEMBERS WE'VE PUT ON ABOUT 800
IN PERSON OR VIRTUAL EVENTS
SPECIFIC TO EDUCATE OUR
POPULATIONS ARE CONSTITUENCIES
ON ALL SORTS OF BENEFITS THEY
MAY HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WHETHER THAT'S HOUSING,
EDUCATION, EMPLOYMENT AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY, WE'VE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO CONNECT THEM WITH
THEIR COMMUNITY BASED SYSTEMS OF
CARE. AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I PERSONALLY HAVE WORKED ON IN
OUR DEPARTMENT IN YEARS PAST,
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S REALLY OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE WELL
CONNECTED WITH OUR DEPARTMENT IN
ADVOCATING FOR AND CONNECTING
VETERANS DIRECTLY ON THE GROUND
WHERE THEY LIVE AND WORK. AND SO
I THINK PROGRAMS LIKE OUR
CALTECH PROGRAM AS WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT OUR CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS. AND WE CONTINUE TO
TWEAK OUR GOALS WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO IMPACT MORE VETERANS
THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE THAT,
WHICH IS REALLY THE FIRST STEP
AND MAKING SURE THAT VETERANS
ARE AWARE OF THE BENEFITS AND
SERVICES THEY HAVE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND THEN, LIKEWISE, REALLY
FOCUSING ON EDUCATING OURSELVES
IN CONCERT WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
ON WHAT IT IS OUR VETERANS ARE
EXPERIENCING ON THE GROUND. SO
UM, YOU ASKED HOW HOW YOU MAY BE
HELPFUL OR OTHERS MAY BE
HELPFUL. I THINK IT'S ANY TIME
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH A VETERAN
IN YOUR DISTRICT, YOU KNOW, OR
OR WITH A STAKEHOLDER PROVIDER.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HELP YOU
WITH THAT. ADDITIONALLY GETTING
THE WORD OUT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
IS IN MANY WAYS A CONNECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA AND REALLY HAS
CREATED THIS NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS, SO IF A VETERAN COMES
TO US, WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CONNECT THEM DIRECTLY WITH THE
SERVICES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU, MADAM PRO TIM.
WE PITCH HITTING, SO WE DID NOT
GET A CHANCE TO MEET RIGHT.
ALTHOUGH I HEARD YOU HAD A
LOVELY CONVERSATION WITH THE
SHOWBOAT AND SHE SUPPORTED SO,
THEREFORE, UM, SUPPORTIVE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. WE'RE GOING ON
THAT I WILL TELL YOU I'M GOING
TO. I USED TO FLY ALL THE SAME
AIRPORT WITH DR VETO AND I'M
GOING TO MISS HIM. I KNOW MANY
ANIMATED CONVERSATIONS. GREAT
GREAT GUY. HEARD, YOU'RE GOING
TO BE EVEN BETTER, SO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. I DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION BECAUSE NOW I'M
HERE. I'M GOING TO REPRESENT MY
DISTRICT SYSTEM HERE. MY FIRST
APPOINTMENT I RECEIVED
POLITICALLY I WAS 28 YEARS OLD
AS A POINTED TO AS A TRUSTEE OF
THE CITY LIBRARY BY THEN, MAYOR
PETE KNIGHT OBVIOUSLY WENT ON TO
BIGGER AND BETTER THINGS.
ORIGINAL PROMISE OF THE PETE
KNIGHT VETERANS HOME WAS THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE SKILLED
NURSING THERE AT SOME POINT, AND
THAT STILL IS NOT HAPPENED. SO I
WOULD IF YOU COULD LOOK INTO
THAT BECAUSE IT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE DO NEED AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THAT'S A WONDERFUL
HOME ARE LANCASTER VETERANS
HOME, WHICH CURRENTLY HAS YOU
KNOW AS YOU'RE AWARE, JUST ONE
LEVEL OF CARE, WHICH IS OUR OUR
CF OR ASSISTED LIVING LEVEL OF
CARE. I'M AWARE THAT THE HOMES
LANCASTER IN VENTURA WHEN THEY
WERE BUILT MANY, MANY YEARS AGO,
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
EXPECTATION WITH THOSE,
INCLUDING SOME LAND TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT. WHAT I WILL SAY IS,
THIS IS ALL PART OF OUR PROCESS
OF EVALUATION. WE WERE ASKED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP A
SERIES OF MASTER PLANS FOR OUR
EIGHT VETERANS HOMES. EVERY FIVE
YEARS. WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF
THE HOMES WRIT LARGE. AND THEN
IN EACH INTERVENING YEAR, WE'RE
LOOKING AT SPECIFIC HOMES COMING
UP SOON WILL BE A REPORT FOR
WEST LOS ANGELES, WHICH IS
REALLY THE GLAVINE HOMES WEST
LOS ANGELES FINTOR IN LANCASTER,
AND I WOULD SAY, UM, THE
EVALUATION OF WHAT TO DO WITH
OUR HOMES IN THE FUTURE AND WHAT
LEVELS OF CARE WE'RE PROVIDING
AT THOSE HOMES REALLY NEEDS TO
MATCH OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
DEMAND. THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO WITH
OUR HOMES. SO UM, IN ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN EVALUATE THE DEMAND
FOR LANCASTER THAT POPULATION
AND SEE WHAT MAKES THE MOST
SENSE WILL CERTAINLY BE DOING SO
AND SO FAR AS IT FITS WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THAT STATUTE, I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
AGAIN. CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU. AND IT REALLY
APPRECIATED MEETING AND ACTUALLY
WE MET SHORTLY AFTER YOU WERE
APPOINTED UNRELATED TO THIS AND
SO I THINK IT'S A TRIBUTE TO ARE
YOU REACHING OUT? I REALLY
APPRECIATED OUR MEETING AND IT
CAUSED MY CHIEF OF STAFF TO ASK
ME A QUESTION BECAUSE WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT WORLD WAR,
ONE VETERANS, AND I SAID THE
LAST ONE DIED IN 2011, HE TURNED
AND SAID, HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
WE'RE WHICH WAS GOOD? UM AND I
HAVE A THROWAWAY QUESTION BEFORE
GETTING TO ONE THAT FOLLOWS UP
ON SENATOR WILK AND THE
THROWAWAYS. THERE'S ANOTHER
SENATOR TALKED TO ME AND SO HE
ASKED IF I WOULD ASK YOU IF YOU
WOULD RETURN PHONE CALLS FROM
SENATORS, IF YOU HAPPEN TO GET
THEM ABOUT AN ISSUE. I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY RETURNED PHONE CALLS
IF I GET THEM. SO UM, I HAVE
RECEIVED A FEW ALREADY,
ESPECIALLY AFTER MY CONFIRMATION
OR AFTER MY APPOINTMENT, WHICH I
GREATLY APPRECIATED. BUT OF
COURSE I WOULD. I WOULD FOLLOW
UP. THANK YOU. AND THEN I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR WILKES
AND IT'S WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT AT
LENGTH. THERE HAS BEEN A BIG
MOVE. IT'S IN A PART OF MY
DISTRICT TO TRY TO HAVE A NEW
VETERANS HOME IN MONTEREY AND
YOUR PREDECESSOR. BASICALLY SAID
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF VETERAN
NUMBER OF VETERANS IS GOING DOWN
AND IF THERE WERE ABLE TO BE UM
A PRIORITY BASED ON
UNREPRESENTED AREAS WITH
HOSPITALS. THERE WOULD BE 23 OR
FOUR URBAN AREAS IN FRONT OF IN
LINE AND BASICALLY THAT THERE
WAS NO INTENT TO DO NEW VETERANS
HOSPITALS ANYWAY. AND YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT IN A MINUTE, IF
YOU LIKE. BUT THE QUESTION THAT
CAME FROM IT IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
THE NUMBER OF VETERANS IS
SHRINKING, AS SENATOR WILK GOT
TOWARD THE NUMBER OF THOSE THAT
NEED MEMORY CARE OR ASSISTED
LIVING OR SKILLED NURSING IS
GOING UP BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC IS, AND THERE'S BEEN
REAL TROUBLE. MEETING THAT
DEMAND. AND SO THE QUESTION IS
IN IN SOME WAYS. HOW MUCH IS THE
DEMAND YOUR INABILITY TO FILL
POSITIONS IN THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE SOME VACANCIES, BUT THEY'RE
NOT IN THE RIGHT PLACE. AND HOW
MUCH IS THE FACT THAT THERE'S
JUST A GREATER DEMAND THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO MEET? RIGHT
I APPRECIATE THAT. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AS WELL. SENATOR
LAIRD. I'VE ENJOYED MEETING WITH
YOU AND OBVIOUSLY TREATING SOME
GOOD STORIES ABOUT, UM EUROPE
AND LANGUAGE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. UM I WOULD SAY, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THE CURRENT STAFFING
VACANCIES WERE FACING AMONG OUR
VETERANS HOMES ARE A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC. OF
COURSE, LIKE ANY OTHER
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY. WE WERE HIT
PRETTY HARD WITH BURNOUT, WITH
PEOPLE DECIDING TO LEAVE THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY ALTOGETHER
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
FILLING VACANCIES AS QUICKLY AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN NOW. WE'RE
RUNNING ON AVERAGE ABOUT 26% SO
WE HAVE A VACANCY RATE OF 26%
ACROSS ALL OF OUR POSITIONS
ACROSS ALL OF OUR HOMES AND
WITHIN SPECIFIC CLASS JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS. THOSE RUN
HIGHER. UM THAT MEANS THAT IF IN
LICENSED CARE, WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
FILL SPECIFIC VACANCIES FOR
STAFFING WERE NOT ABLE TO MEET
PATIENT HOURS PER DAY. THAT
MEANS THAT WE CAN'T BACK FILL
OUR VACANT BEDS. AND SO WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF LOWER CENSUS THAN
NORMAL BECAUSE AGAIN OF THE PEN
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE
OF NATURAL ATTRITION, AND
BECAUSE WE PAUSED AND SLOWED
DOWN SOME OF OUR SOME OF OUR, UH
, ENTRANCES INTO THE HOME TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AGAINST COVID,
AND FOR THAT WE WERE SUCCESSFUL,
BUT AS A RESULT, WE NEED TO RAMP
THAT BACK UP. SO WE ARE WORKING
ON A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES TO
INCREASE OUR STAFFING AND
HIRING. TO BACK FILL THOSE
VACANCIES, WHICH WILL THEN IN
TURN, ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON
FILLING BEDS AGAIN. BEFORE WE DO
ANYTHING ELSE AND ENTERTAIN ANY
OTHER IDEAS ABOUT NEW HOMES
COMING ONLINE. THE FOCUS REALLY
SHOULD BE JUST THAT IN OUR HOMES
. OUR FOCUS SHOULD BE BACK,
FILLING OUR STAFFING VACANCIES
AND GETTING OUR CENSUS BACK TO
AN OPTIMIZED LEVEL SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
VETERANS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
SERVE THROUGH THE EIGHT HOMES
THAT WE HAVE. TO YOUR QUESTION,
THOUGH I ABSOLUTELY THINK THE
DEMAND IS GOING TO OUTPACE
ANYTHING WE ALREADY PROVIDE
ABSENT OF ANY STAFFING VACANCIES
, OR THE NUMBER OF BEDS WE HAVE.
THE DEMAND IS JUST SIMPLY GOING
UP. SO UM, THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN WE'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF BUILDING NEW HOMES,
THOUGH, BECAUSE THIS IS A POLICY
THAT THE V A IS MOVING AWAY FROM
THEIR FOCUSING INSTEAD ON
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES, FOR
EXAMPLE, UM, WHICH WE'RE
BUILDING A NEW SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY TO REPLACE THE
HOLDERMAN HOSPITAL AND OUR YACHT
BILL VETERANS HOME, SO THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THAT FOCUS AND
ATTENTION WITH THE B A IS
THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT HOW TO
PROVIDE INCREASED IN HOME CARE
FOR OUR VETERANS WHO NEED THAT
THAT LEVEL OF CARE. SO, UM ANY
HOME THAT WOULD BE OUT FOR
CONSIDERATION IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT A REGION WHERE WE
WOULD WANT TO BUILD A NEW HOME,
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT I WANT TO
ENTERTAIN. AT THIS TIME, IT
WOULD REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
SPECIFIC CRITERIA THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR 2020 MASTER
PLAN AND THAT WE OVERLAID AND
EVALUATED ALL OF OUR CURRENT
HOMES WITH AND THOSE FIVE
CRITERIA INCLUDE PROXIMITY TO V,
A CARE THE HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE SURROUNDING THE
AREA. THE NEED OF VETERANS SO
ACTUAL ACUITY AND IF THEIR LEVEL
OF CARE IS NEEDED IN THAT
VETERAN POPULATION THE SIZE OF
THE VETERAN POPULATION AS IT
EXISTS, AND THE WORKFORCE
AVAILABILITY IN THOSE SPECIFIC
POSITIONS. I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW AND THIS IS PUBLIC
INFORMATION AS WELL. ANYONE CAN
VISIT OUR MASTER PLAN REPORT ON
OUR WEBSITE. NONE OF OUR CURRENT
HOMES MEETS ALL FIVE CRITERIA,
AND THAT WOULD REALLY BE, UM
WHAT YOU WOULD WANT IDEALLY TO
BE ABLE TO CREATE A NEW VETERANS
HOME AT THIS POINT. MY GOAL IS
TO FOCUS ON THE EIGHT THAT WE
HAVE. WE HAVE LOTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE HOMES, AND WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
ONLY MAINTAINING AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT CARING FOR
IT, AS IS NECESSARY FOR
LICENSING AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE ARE CONTINUED HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE RESIDENTS
WANT TO LIVE, UM THERE AND LIVE
OUT THEIR FINAL DAYS IN. AND
FORTUNATELY, SENATOR GROWS OUT
OF THE ROOM BECAUSE THEN I CAN
REFER TO MY PRIOR JOB, BUT, UH,
BECAUSE I'M AWARE THAT IF YOU
ARE IN A POSITION THAT YOU'RE IN
, YOU CAN'T GET OUT IN FRONT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND ASKING
FOR THINGS. IT IS AN
ADMINISTRATION ASK BUT FROM YOUR
COMMENTS, I WOULD GLEAN THAT IF
YOU NEEDED MORE HELP, IT MIGHT
BE IN FIGURING OUT HOW THERE'S
MORE RESOURCES FOR ASSISTED
LIVING OR MEMORY CARE OR WHETHER
THERE'S SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY
FOR IN HOME CARE THAT THAT MIGHT
BE SOMETHING THAT THAT HELPS
MEET THE DEMAND AND THE ONE
OBSERVATION I WOULD MAKE. THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT IN OUR MEETING
IS THAT AT SOME POINT IN THIS
WHOLE DISCUSSION THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS ONE OF THE BENCHMARKS
WAS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE ON A WAITING LIST, AND I
HAD A BIG PUSHBACK FROM A
VETERAN SERVICE OFFICER IN MY
DISTRICT, SAYING, THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WON'T EVEN GO
ON TO WIDENING LIST BECAUSE THEY
SEE IT SO LONG. THAT THEY WANT
SIGN UP, SO USING IT AS A
BENCHMARK FOR WHAT UNMET NEED IS
NOT TOTALLY RELIABLE. AND SO I
WOULD JUST OFFER THAT AS WELL
BECAUSE AND IT IS DIFFICULT IN
PLACES THAT ARE FARTHER AWAY.
UM, I KNOW IN THE MONTEREY BAY
AREA NOW THERE'S FINALLY A V, A
FACILITY OF SORTS IN MONTEREY.
BUT THE BIG DEAL WAS
TRANSPORTATION TO PALO ALTO AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
PEOPLE OF THEIR FOR THEIR CARE
BECAUSE GENERALLY IF THEY NEEDED
INTENSE CARE, THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DRIVE AND THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
HAVE A CAR. AND SO THAT WAS THE
BARRIER AND GETTING THEM TO THE
V. A AND THE INSTRUCTIVE THING
THAT YOU JUST SAID, AND YOU SAID
YESTERDAY IS IT ALSO IS NOT JUST
A CLEAR DECISION. OF YOU AS AS A
STATE OFFICIAL AND VETERANS,
MAKING THIS CERTAIN THINGS HAVE
TO BE APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
VIA OR THEY HAVE TO BE INVOLVED
IN CONSTRUCTION OR GRANTS OR
OTHER THINGS, AND EVEN IF YOU
WANTED TO DO CERTAIN THINGS
WITHOUT THAT, THAT'S NOT THE
CASE THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THE VIA THROUGH THERE'VE A HOME
LOAN OR HOME CONSTRUCTION GRANT.
REIMBURSES UP TO 65% OF THE
CONSTRUCTION COST DEVASTATE
VETERANS HOME. RIGHT NOW, UM,
THERE WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
POPULATION OF VETERANS OF ANY
STATE IN THE NATION NUMBER TWO
WOULD BE TEXAS NUMBER THREE
WOULD BE FLORIDA. TEXAS HAS. I
THINK EIGHT OR NINE VETERANS
HOMES AND FLORIDA HAS EIGHT
HOMES, SO I DON'T SEE ANY STATES
EXCEEDING THAT AVERAGE NUMBER IN
GENERAL. AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES HAVE FAR FEWER HOMES THAN
THAT. AND YET THEY HAVE GREATER
DEMAND AND NEED. SO WHEN GOING
INTO THIS ENDEAVOR OF LOOKING AT
BUILDING A NEW HOME. ANY STATE
IS COMPETING WITH THOSE
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS WITH ANY
OTHER PRIORITIZATION THE V M A C
AS A HIGHER PRIORITY FROM
ANOTHER STATE. THANK YOU. I
THINK THIS WHOLE EXCHANGE IS THE
REASON I'M GONNA BE REALLY HAPPY
TO VOTE FOR YOUR CONFERENCE
VERSION. YOU'RE ON TOP OF IT.
YOU'RE KNOWLEDGEABLE AND YOU'RE
PREPARED TO ACT SO I THANK THANK
YOU, SIR. RESPONSIVE SENATOR
LARRY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND TO JUMP OFF
OF YOUR LAST POINT, UM I WAS
THRILLED TO SEE THE GOVERNOR
MAKE DISAPPOINTMENT. I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE HAD DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF
YOU AND WORKED WITH YOU FOR
ALMOST A DECADE, IF NOT A LITTLE
BIT LONGER, AND, UM IT'S CLEAR
WHEN I SEE YOU WITHOUT NOTES,
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS WITH
WHAT THE SITUATION IS, SO I
THINK WE ARE. WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
EXPERIENCE. UM SO THANK YOU AND
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THAT. UM,
THESE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS. UM YOU
KNOW, I WANTED TO KNOW IN TERMS
OF, UM THE IN HOME HEALTH ISSUE.
ARE WE ABLE, UH, WHAT ARE YOU
ABLE WE HAVE RESOURCES RIGHT NOW
TO WORK ON THAT. OR IS THAT JUST
A FUTURE THING THAT YOU ARE
HOPING WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IN
TERMS OF, UH, YOU KNOW, SERVICES
FOR VETERANS. I THINK A SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE THAT I'M
PROUD OF RIGHT NOW IS OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS AND I
WAS GOING TO GET TO THAT
WONDERFUL. GO RIGHT AHEAD. WE
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A CHANCE TO
MEET MA'AM MADAM PRO TEM. I JUST
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS FOR
VETERANS ISSUES. YOU AND I HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER ON A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS ADVOCATING FOR WOMEN
VETERANS, FOR EXAMPLE, AND JUST
ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OVER THE YEARS. UM IN HOME
HEALTH CARE IS SOMETHING THAT
THE V A IS ABLE TO PROVIDE WHEN
VETERANS QUALIFY FOR
COMPENSATION BENEFITS, AND
THAT'S WHAT'S SO GREAT ABOUT CAL
VET AND OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS. THEY HOLD OUR POWER OF
ATTORNEY SO THAT THEY CAN SUBMIT
CLAIMS FOR VETERANS ON BEHALF OF
THE DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM. THAT
INCLUDES ACCREDITING THEM.
TRAINING THEM CLEAR OVERSIGHT OF
THEIR WORKLOAD UNITS AND THEN,
OF COURSE, THE PENSION FUNDING
THAT GOES DIRECTLY TO THOSE
COUNTY OFFICES. THEY ARE KIND OF
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND FOR WHAT
WE DO IN TERMS OF FIRST
CONNECTING WITH VETERANS AND
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE A NUMBER
OF SERVICES TO THEM, AND THAT
WILL INCLUDE DISABILITY AND
COMPENSATION PENSION. AH
SURVIVORS INDEMNITY COMPENSATION
AND CAN INCLUDE QUALIFICATIONS
SO THAT THE VETERAN CAN RECEIVE
SUPPORT FOR IN HOME CARE. I WAS
GOING TO THAT WAS GOING TO BE MY
NEXT QUESTION. YOUR RELATIONSHIP
CURRENTLY WITH THE 5656 CORRECT?
YES THAT IS REALLY WONDERFUL TO
HEAR THAT THE RELATIONSHIP IS
VERY STRONG. IT IS. YOU KNOW,
THE LAST QUESTION, BECAUSE I
REALLY FEEL LIKE PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED A LOT OF QUESTIONS, AND
CERTAINLY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
OUR HOMES HAVE, YOU KNOW BE ABLE
TO MEET THE CAPACITY BUT TO
SENATOR LAIRD'S POINT ABOUT, UM
YOU KNOW THE INFRASTRUCTURAL
NEEDS OF THE SYSTEM. NOT JUST,
UH BRICKS AND MORTAR. AND MAKING
SURE YOU KNOW IT IS INTACT AND
SAFE AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS BUT
THE OPERATIONAL PIECE THAT 25
MILLION INCREASE IN NURSING
OPERATIONS, I THINK FOR THE 2324
BUDGET, UM YOU KNOW, NURSING
SHORTAGES OR ACROSS THE BOARD A
PROBLEM. THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND SYSTEMS, VARIOUS SYSTEMS.
HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO COMPETE?
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR STRATEGY FOR
COMPETING TO GET NURSING
ADEQUATE NURSING STAFF, RIGHT?
WELL UM, FIRST, THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING THAT
ASK SO THAT WE COULD GET THROUGH
THESE TIMES WITH CONTINUED
SUPPORT FROM THE NURSING
REGISTRY THAT THAT'S BEEN VERY
HELPFUL. IT'S ALLOWED US TO
MAINTAIN OUR LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE TO OUR
VETERANS. BUT THAT'S NOT A LONG
TERM SOLUTION ARE LONG TERM
SOLUTION SHOULD BE TO CONTINUE
TO BACK FILL THOSE VACANCIES.
AND ACHIEVE WHAT WE HOPE TO BE A
MORE COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THERE WAS SUCCESS THIS YEAR WITH
ACHIEVING SOME OF THE NOT JUST
GENERAL SALARY INCREASES THROUGH
BARGAINING, BUT ALSO SOME
ADDITIONAL STATEMENTS. THAT WAS
HELPFUL. WE HOPE THAT THAT
BRINGS MORE PEOPLE TO THE TABLE.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON DOING OUR
BEST TO LET PEOPLE KNOW THROUGH
ACTIVE JOB FAIRS. UM AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THAT
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK
AT OUR VETERANS HOMES OR TAPPING
INTO, I THINK MUCH MORE STRONGLY
OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR COLLEGES
THAT HAVE SOME OF THESE
HEALTHCARE PIPELINES AS WE'D
LIKE TO REALLY BUILD THAT
PIPELINE FOR THE FUTURE. IN CASE
WE RUN INTO THESE CHALLENGES
DOWN THE ROAD. AND WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT EMPLOYEE RETENTION.
HOW DO WE CONNECT EVERY EMPLOYEE
AT CAL VET TO OUR IMPORTANT
MISSION AND MAKE SURE THEY FEEL
VALUED AND SUPPORTED AS
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
TRAINING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE THE BEST SERVICES AND
CARE TO OUR VETERANS? UM AND
EMPLOYEE FOCUS AND GETTING OUT
AND TALKING TO OUR STAFF AT CAL
VET IS ONE OF MY TOP GOALS AS
WELL. BECAUSE I THINK AFTER THE
PANDEMIC, UM THERE'S A LOT OF
BURNOUT. PEOPLE ARE WANTING TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO CHANGE WITH
NEW LEADERSHIP. AND ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS I CAN DO IS GET OUT
AND JUST HAVE MORE FACE TIME
WITH OUR FOLKS AND KNOW THAT WE
ARE SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THEY DO, AND WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THEM MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WHERE
WE CAN I THINK THOSE THINGS CAN
HELP MAKE US MORE COMPETITIVE AS
AN ORGANIZATION. UM I THINK WE
AS YOU KNOW, NOT AN INDEPENDENT
HEALTH CARE FACILITY, BUT
INSTEAD AS A STATE HAVE AMAZING
BENEFITS THAT ANYBODY WOULD BE
SHOULD BE EXCITED TO COME WORK
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
SERVING OUR VETERANS. THE PEOPLE
WHO DO WORK FOR US ARE SO HAPPY
AND THIS IS WHAT I JUST IF I CAN
TAKE A MOMENT TO PRAISE OUR CAL
VET STAFF, REALLY. THESE ARE
JUST THE MOST COMMITTED
DEDICATED FOLKS. THEY CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT WHAT THEY DO. AND
EVERY PERSON WE INTERVIEWED FOR
A JOB, WHETHER THEY GET THE JOB
OR NOT. THE FIRST THING THEY
SAY, IS I REALLY JUST WANT TO
WORK AT CALVIN BECAUSE I LOVE
SERVING VETERANS. THEY EITHER
HAVE A CONNECTION THEY HAVE
SERVED IN THE MILITARY
THEMSELVES. IT IS REALLY A
CALLING AT OUR DEPARTMENT, AND I
THINK THAT'S JUST A UNIQUE, UM,
PLACE TO BE IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
SO IF WE CAN CONTINUE TO CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH THAT MISSION AND
MAKE THEM FEEL REALLY VALUED
WITH THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
EVERY DAY, I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPETITIVE IN THAT. IN THAT
HEALTHCARE SETTING. WELL THANK
YOU AND I WOULD SAY THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THAT
IN ACTION IN ANY EVENT I'VE EVER
BEEN TO RELATED TO STAFF AND AH,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS MICE,
MY SISTER. THAT UH, THAT THE
VICE CHAIR ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGES
AHEAD OF ME. AH LEFT THE NAVY,
UH, IN SAN DIEGO WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL, COURTESY OF THE MILITARY
AND BECAME A NURSE, AND THEN HER
FIRST PRIORITY WAS TO WORK AT
AVIVA. UM YEAH, IN SOUTH IN THE
SOUTH. UM SO AND SHE WAS
COMMITTED TO THAT. AND SO I KNOW
THAT IT IS A FAMILY. I KNOW THAT
IT IS A CALLING AND WE THANK YOU
AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF. UM IF
THERE ARE NO MORE QUESTIONS, IT
IS NOW TIME FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
A MICROPHONE HERE IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
SUPPORT, I NEED YOUR NAME YOUR
TITLE IF ANY OR SO ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE ASSOCIATED WITH AND VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS. WELCOME
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS SETH REBIRTH RE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION AND
BET, CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS. CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDERS, VETERANS COUNCIL
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA, VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
LINDSAY SENDS CONFIRMATION IS
CALVET SECRETARY OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS, I'VE HAD THE DISTINCT
PLEASURE OF WORKING. WITH ACTING
SECRETARY LINDSEY SIN.
THROUGHOUT HER TENURE. SHE HAS
HELD VARIOUS KEY LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
GAINING A SOUND UNDERSTANDING OF
ITS MISSION. AND THE VETERANS IT
SERVES. WE APPLAUD HER
DEDICATION AND WELL BEING OF
VETERANS AND HER TIRELESS EFFORT
TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES. ON THE
SAND IS THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE
JOB. HER TRACK RECORD SPEAKS
VOLUMES ABOUT HER COMMITMENT,
LEADERSHIP AND PASSION. FOR
SERVICE OF OUR NATION'S HEROES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH HER AS HER IN HER ROLE AS
SECRETARY OF CALVET. IT'S WITH
GREAT ENTHUSIASM AND CONFIDENCE
THAT WE ¿ER OUR
FOR HER APPOINTMENT AS CALVERT
SECRETARY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. THERE WE GO. OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAT. HODGES
PRESIDENT, CEO OF HSP SOLUTIONS.
WE HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME SERVICE
PROVIDER. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MANY FACETS. I'M
ALSO A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
MYSELF, AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
IN SUPPORT OF LINDSAY. SHE'S
COMPASSIONATE. SHE IS SHE IS
EMPATHETIC. SHE KNOWS WHAT THE
MISSION IS OF CALVET BECAUSE SHE
LIVES IT AND SHE'S A VETERAN
HERSELF. UM AND SO YOU KNOW,
IT'S PRETTY EASY TO GET BEHIND
HER, AND SHE HOLDS EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY DO. AND I'VE SEEN IT IN
PERSON. I'VE SEEN IT IN THE
HOSPITALS. I THINK IT INTER
STAFF AND I'VE SEEN IT IN THE
VETERANS THAT SHE SERVES. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT SHE HAS A
FUNNY SAYING SHE DOESN'T WANT TO
BE GOOD. SHE WANTS TO BE GREAT,
AND SHE DOESN'T JUST SAY THAT
SHE LIVES IT EVERY DAY, AND SHE
HOLDS HER ENTIRE LEADERSHIP
TEAM, MANY OF WHICH ARE HERE
TODAY ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT AS
WELL AND IT'S A BLESSING TO BE
ABLE TO BE A PARTNER TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TWO
LINDSAY AND HER LEADERSHIP GROUP
AT CALVET. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
WELCOME THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
TOM D'AGOSTINO AND WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE VETERAN FOUNDATION. AND
WE'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH LINDSAY FOR I THINK
THE DAY HE WALKED IN THE DOOR.
WE'VE HAD OUR FUN TIMES AND OUR
HARD TIMES, BUT I CAN SAY
UNEQUIVOCALLY. HER LEADERSHIP
AND INSIGHT AND EXPERTISE. THERE
IS VERY PROMISING FOR THE FUTURE
OF CALVIN. IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
WORK WITH HER AND HER STAFF. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. WELCOME MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS HERE IN READ. I
COULD HAVE NOT COME AT THAT
TIME, DO IT BECAUSE TOM HAS BEEN
WITH ME FOR OVER 20 YEARS AND
HE'S SUPER AND HE'S GOT A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH LINDSAY. BY
THE WAY, MY DAUGHTER'S NAME IS
LINDSAY SPELLED THE SAME WAY. SO
UM, HAS BEEN A PLEASURE. I'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE TO BE IN A LOT OF
THOSE MEETINGS AND YOU WON'T
FIND A BETTER PERSON TO EVER
EVER LEAVE THIS PLACE. I THOUGHT
WE COULDN'T BE VITO. HE WAS
GREAT, BUT LINDSAY IS TOP OF THE
GAME. AND YOU'VE HEARD HER THIS
AFTERNOON AND SHE'S DOING A BANG
UP JOB. AND IT'S NOT AN EASY
JOB. AND I CAN TELL YOU BECAUSE
I HAVE I HAVE NEVER ADDED IT UP,
BUT PORK HAS 75,000 MEMBERS.
THOUSANDS OF THEM ARE VETERANS,
HOWEVER, TROLL ASSOCIATION,
WHICH WE PROBABLY REPRESENT THEM
AS WELL, HAS 14,000 ACTIVE AND
RETIRED MEMBERS AND MANY
THOUSANDS OF THEM ARE VETERANS.
AND UM HOW FIRE SAME SAME THING.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. STAY
WITH IT. WE'RE PROUD TO BE HERE
AND SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY
UH, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? OKAY I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DIETS
FOR EMOTION. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WILK, THE VICE CHAIR IS GOING TO
BE VERY UPSET THAT SHE DIDN'T
GET TO MAKE HIS PROMOTION. BUT
TO BE HERE SHE IS AT HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL BE YOU KNOW SHE'S
GOT DOUBLE DUTY TODAY, BUT WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN BECAUSE
I THINK SHE ALREADY EXPRESSED
HER SUPPORT. SO YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HER
COMING BACK. AND UH, YOU KNOW,
GIVEN A SURPRISE VOTE IN
OPPOSITION, THAT LIKELY IS NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR WILK FOR STEPPING IN AND
MAKING THE MOST SHIN LET ME ASK
MADAM SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL. LAIRD I SWALLOWED CUEVAS
SMALL EQUIVALENCY WILK HIGH
GROVE. ATKINS I WE WILL PUT THIS
ON CALL. CONGRATULATIONS AND
AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU. EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HMM. OKAY. SHOULD WE TAKE A
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE JUST ABOUT A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK, SO WE'LL BE
PROMPTLY BACK IN FIVE MINUTES.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND STAY WITH US.
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS, AND AGAIN, OUR VICE
CHAIR WILL BE BACK. SHE IS AT
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND, UM WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND INVITE UP OUR
SECOND CONTRARY, UM WHICH IS A
POSITION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. NO EMMY
GALLARDO. I'M GOING TO HOPE I
SAID YOUR NAME CORRECTLY. UM
WELCOME AND AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. UM I WILL INVITE
YOU TO DO THE SAME, WHICH IS,
UH, THANK ANYONE ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS WELCOME.
THANK YOU STARTED THIS GOOD
AFTERNOON. MADKINS AND SENATORS.
I'M HONORED AND HUMBLED TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR THIS APPOINTMENT.
I WILL INTRODUCE MY GUESTS. I AM
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE A VILLAGE
WITH ME. SO UM UH FIRST OFF MY
PARENTS, CONNIE AND HIS SEUSS.
THEY ARE BY CHAMPIONS FROM THE
BEGINNING. HE'S RAISING HIS
HAND. HE DOESN'T MY DAD DOESN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH VERY WELL. BUT I
TOLD HIM TO RAISE HIS HAND WHEN
HE HEARD HIS NAME, AND THEY
INCULCATED IN ME. THE UM YOU
KNOW, TO ALWAYS KNOW THAT SEE
CEP WEATHER. YES YOU CAN REALLY
APPRECIATE THEM BEING HERE TO
WITNESS THIS. I ALSO HAVE HERE.
MY PARTNER IN LIFE, EMILIO
CAMACHO. HE'S RAISING HIS HAND.
HE WE HAVE HIS SON, MILITO, WHO
IS A BUDDY OF MINE, AND ALSO MY
UNOFFICIALLY ADOPTED SON. ALSO
HERE IS MY FATHER IN LAW. JAVIER
ALSO HAVE MY TWO KIDS AND THEN
AND CHILL ITO THAN LOOKS
GORGEOUS IN HIS SUIT, BUT HE'S
SO UNCOMFORTABLE, SO I DON'T
KNOW IF HE'S GOING TO SMILE FOR
US OR NOT WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
VERY QUIET, SO I'M PROUD OF
THEM. I ALSO HAVE HERE. MY
BROTHER MANUEL. HE LOOKS BIGGER
THAN ME. BUT HE WILL FOREVER BE
MY LITTLE BROTHER AND HIS
DAUGHTER, MY NIECE SOLANA, WHO
IS ALSO MY GOD, DAUGHTER. THEY
BOTH FLEW FROM TEXAS TO BE HERE
FOR THIS HEARING. SOME REALLY
GRATEFUL TO THEM FOR DOING THAT.
I ALSO HAVE MY FRIEND BO HERE
BEEN A GOOD FRIEND OF OUR FAMILY
FOR A LONG TIME. HOW MY CHIEF OF
STAFF ERIC STOKES. MY SPECIAL
ADVISER, JIMMY ACUNA, WHO BOTH
MAKE MY LIFE MUCH EASIER BECAUSE
OF HOW GREAT THEY ARE. ALSO HERE
IS BRADY BORCHARD NG, WHO IS THE
LEAD OF OUR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
OFFICE. HE'S GOING THROUGH THIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS WITH ME IS
OUR FIRST TIME HE'S BEEN DOING A
WONDERFUL JOB REALLY
APPRECIATING HIM AND SEVERAL OF
THEIR COLLEAGUES FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION, WHICH I WON'T LIST
OUT AT THIS POINT AND SOME OTHER
FRIENDS WHO ARE HERE, BUT
THEY'LL INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
THROUGH THE COMMENT. PERIOD. AND
SO I DID WANT TO START OUT BY
TELLING YOU THE THREE KEY
REASONS WHY I'M MOTIVATED TO
SERVE IN THE ROLE OF
COMMISSIONER FIRST I AM A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE WHO WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN VENTURA COUNTY AND
EDUCATED AT THREE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. ALL OF MY EMPLOYMENT
HAS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
PRIVATE, NONPROFIT AND
PHILANTHROPIC SECTORS, INCLUDING
EIGHT YEARS WORKING IN ENERGY.
AND I ALSO ESTABLISHED MY OWN
SMALL BUSINESS AS A CERTIFIED
SPANISH INTERPRETER, SO WORKING
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR NOW IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO CONTRIBUTE
BACK TO MY HOME STATE. ALL THAT
MY FAMILY AND I HAVE BEEN
BENEFITED FROM LIVING HERE AND
THAT ALSO MAKES ME EVEN MORE
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING OTHERS
TO ACHIEVE PROSPERITY IN THE
ENERGY SPACE IS I HAVE SECOND AS
A LATINA AND POSSIBLY THE FIRST
TO BE APPOINTED AS A CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSIONER. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT I'M NOT ONLY
REFLECTING THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
, BRINGING A UNIQUE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS THE DAUGHTER OF
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS, HAVING LIVED
IN A MIXED IMMIGRATION STATUS
HOUSEHOLD BEING IN AN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER BEING A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GRADUATE. AND
GROWING UP LOW INCOME. THIS
EXPERIENCE GIVES ME A VERY
PRAGMATIC OUTLOOK, FOCUSING ON
HOW THE COMMISSION CAN CONTINUE
IMPROVING OUR PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES TO BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS, STARTING WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN HURT, FIRST
AND WORST AND MOST CLIMATE
CHALLENGES. THIRD I AM A MOTHER
WHO WANTS TO BE A GOOD ROLE
MODEL FOR MY KIDS HAVE AN INCH
ALITO. AND ALSO FOR YOUNG WOMEN
LIKE MY GOD, DAUGHTER SOLANA,
SHOWING THEM THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEADERSHIP. SERVICE AND TAKING
CARE OF OUR NATURAL RESOURCES,
ADDITIONALLY AND WHAT TO IMPROVE
OUR ENVIRONMENT TO ENSURE THEY
AND THE GENERATIONS AFTER THEM
HAVE HEALTHIER OUTCOMES, AND
I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING THAT MY TOP
PRIORITIES OR FIRST AS ATTORNEY
COMMISSIONER TO LEAD WITH
INTEGRITY AND ENSURE THE
COMMISSION ABIDES BY THE LAW
WHILE PURSUING OUR MISSION OF
LEADING THE STATE TO 100% CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE FOR ALL. SECOND AS
A NEW COMMISSIONER AND EDUCATING
MYSELF ON ALL THE ISSUES. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IS ADDRESSING,
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM. AND
CONNECTED TO THAT, BECAUSE OF MY
UNIQUE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, I AM
COMMITTING TO APPLYING A
COMMUNITY PERSPECTIVE WHEN I
ADDRESSED THE WORK, WHICH
REQUIRES LISTENING AND LEARNING
FROM THE PUBLIC AND TREATING
THEM AS EXPERTS. I ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE A
VOICE AND THIS REQUIRES
IDENTIFYING WAYS TO ENGAGE EARLY
, OFTEN AND MEANINGFULLY WITH
TRIBES AND COMMUNITIES,
PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM RURAL
AREAS AND LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN HARMED BY POLICIES
OF THE PAST OR LEFT OUT OF
OPPORTUNITIES IN CLEAN ENERGY.
AND THIRD, I AM PRIORITIZING THE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF TWO
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION THAT WILL SPAN
MY TERM, WHICH ARE THE LITHIUM
VALLEY VISION. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH A
LITHIUM ECONOMY ECOSYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA, WHILE INCREASING
PROSPERITY FOR RESIDENTS OF THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY AND THE SALTON
SEA REGION. AND THE OTHER IS TO
OVERSEE THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S NEW OPT IN
CERTIFICATION PROCESS TO HASTEN
THE RELIABILITY OF THE GRID WITH
CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES, WELL,
EXPANDING BENEFITS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE THESE PROJECTS
ARE SO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO ME FOR GIVING ME THIS TIME
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DIALOGUE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND YOU REALLY DID BRING A
VILLAGE. YES IT'S AN HONOR TO
HAVE YOUR PARENTS. HERE IT IS. I
THINK PARENTS ALWAYS GET SPECIAL
DISPENSATION WHEN THEY COME
BECAUSE ALL OF US HAVE STORIES.
AND YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THE
STORIES THAT REALLY RESONATE
EMOTIONALLY IN TERMS OF WHAT
PEOPLE LOVE TO DO IN THE PASSION
THEY BRING TO IT. AND THE WORK
ETHIC THAT IS INSTILLED IN YOU,
OBVIOUSLY FROM THOSE INCREDIBLE
PARENTS, AND OF COURSE TO
EVERYONE ELSE, I DIDN'T MEAN TO
IGNORE ANYONE, BUT WE ALWAYS
LIKE TO SEE FAMILY. THANK YOU
FOR TOM ATKINS FOR ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT AND THE YOUNG ONES ARE
BEING VERY GOOD WITH OTHER
EXPERIENCES, SO I SHOULD GET AN
EXTRA BONUS POINT FOR THAT,
RIGHT? SURE YOU WILL. YAHOO QUÊ
SENATOR LAIRD, LET ME LET ME
START WITH SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS AND WE'LL JUST COME RIGHT
DOWN THE LINE. GO AHEAD SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT, AND IT'S SO
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN. MRS
GALLARDO WAS THAT GREAT
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD, AND I
ENJOYED IT AS WELL AND
APPRECIATING THE PRIORITIES AND,
UM, YOU KNOW, THE COMMISSION
PLAYS A TREMENDOUS ROLE IN
GUIDING US FORWARD IN THE GOALS
THAT WE HAVE, AND ONE THING THAT
WE TALKED QUITE A BIT ABOUT IS
THE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING AND
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
PARTICULARLY AROUND JOBS AND
CAREER AND EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
SERVICES IN OTHERWISE,
PARTICULARLY FOR OIL AND GAS
WORKERS IN THIS PROCESS OF
TRANSITION. HMM. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT YOU TO
CLARIFY A LITTLE BIT MORE ON IS
JUST HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO
REALLY PRIORITIZE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AS WE ARE? NOT JUST
PRIORITIZING BUT AGGRESSIVELY
MOVING TOWARDS CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS. THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS
BEEN THE LEAD IN SOME OF THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WORK.
EXCITING WE TALKED ABOUT A
NUMBER OF ENERGY PROJECTS AND
THE C E C IS DOING QUITE A BIT
TO ENGAGE COMMUNITIES IN THE
PROCESS. BUT AS WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THE BUILD OUTS, UM YOU ARE
PARTICULARLY IN A POSITION TO BE
LEADING ON THE WORKFORCE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE TARGETS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH STATE
FUNDING. BRING IN
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS.
WHEN I SAY UNDERREPRESENTED,
UNDERREPRESENTED IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDING SPACE
WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND BY THE
LAST ECONOMIC SHIFTS OF THE PAST
. NOW WE'RE MOVING INTO THIS
CLEAN ENERGY SHIFT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE THOSE WORKER PROGRAMS
THAT WE ENSURE THAT OUR
WORKFORCE IS KEEPING PACE WITH
THE AMBITIOUS GOALS? AND
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD. UM REALLY WANT TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT HOW YOU SEE YOUR ROLE
IN MAKING SURE THAT THE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS KEEP PACE
WITH THE GOALS THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. UM I DO APPRECIATE IT,
AND, UH OKAY. I WILL BE VERY
FRANK THAT I DON'T HAVE A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BACKGROUND
. I DON'T HAVE THAT EXPERTISE
AND THAT EXPERIENCE. HOWEVER, I
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE A LIFE WITH DIGNITY
AND BE ABLE TO PROSPER AND HAVE
THE NEXT GENERATION BUILD WEALTH
AND SO FOR, UM FOR MY FAMILY,
THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT. SO I
WANT TO BRING THAT TO THIS WORK.
UM PRIORITIZING IT, EVEN THOUGH
I MAY NOT HAVE THAT TYPE OF
EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO UM, YOU
KNOW, GO DEEP ON IT. SO HERE'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
WE ARE TRYING TO ENGAGE STAFF
MORE DEEPLY ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE AREAS LIKE WORKFORCE.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY YOU KNOW
OF PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE ENERGY QUESTION TO DO, BUT
WE REALIZE IT'S A PRIORITY. SO
WE DO WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
WHAT? WHAT CAN BE DONE. SO WE DO
HAVE, UH, AN INITIATIVE THAT
WE'RE DOING. WE'RE CALLING THEM
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE WHERE
WE'RE ABLE TO BRING STAFF OUT OF
THEIR SILOS IN TERMS OF THEIR
POLICY AREAS TO TALK ABOUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT, SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY, LANGUAGE, ACCESS,
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT AND
OTHER TYPES OF BENEFITS THAT CAN
THAT CAN I'M BRINGING VALUE TO
COMMUNITIES. SO WE'RE HAVING
STAFF TALK ABOUT THAT. AND HOW
CAN WE DO THESE THINGS ADVANCE
THESE THINGS IN OUR PROGRAMS AND
, UM, YOU KNOW, THROUGH THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY'RE WORKING
ON. SO THAT'S PART OF THE
LEARNING. AND SO WE'RE STARTING
THAT OUT. AND THEN WHAT WE ARE
ALSO SEEING IS THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIVISIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDING WORKFORCE AS PART OF
WHAT THEY DO WITH THEIR GRANTS.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, THE FUELS AND
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IS IN
CHARGE OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM, WHICH IS
A BUCKET OF MONIES AND THAT WHAT
THE PROGRAM IS DOING IS
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. RELATED TO
DEVELOPING AND DEPLOYING ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND RELATED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT, AND THE PROGRAM
PROGRAMS WORKFORCE TRAINING
INITIATIVES ARE FUNDED. THAT ARE
FUNDED ARE BROAD BASED
PARTNERSHIPS. SO WE'RE NOT DOING
IT ON OUR OWN. WE ARE LOOKING TO
PARTNER WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
. THERE IS A PROGRAM THAT
THEY'RE DOING WHERE THEY'RE
WHERE THEY'RE PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ALSO THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. SO
FOLKS WHO HAVE THAT TYPE OF
EXPERTISE THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM
AND THAT WE ARE ENSURING IS
HAPPENING. EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT
THE ONES WHO ARE YOU KNOW THE
EXPERTS ON THAT FRONT, SO I
THINK THAT THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS DOING
A REALLY EXCELLENT JOB ON THAT
WORK FIRST FRONT AND ENSURING
THAT THERE THERE ARE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROSPERITY
BECAUSE JOBS ARE ONE OF THE MAIN
WAYS THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING WELL,
ESPECIALLY THOSE FOLKS WHO NEED
THOSE TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES.
THE ANNUAL UPDATE FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
INVESTMENT PLAN IS COMING UP, SO
WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE A BIT
MORE ABOUT, UM YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
THEY'RE CARVING OUT FOR THAT
WORK. FIRST DEVELOPMENT PIECE. I
THINK SENATOR SMALLWOOD QUIVERS.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD UPDATE FOR
YOU TO RECEIVE AND SO WE CAN
FOLLOW UP ON THAT SO THAT YOU
CAN GET MORE SPECIFICS ON I
DON'T NEED THAT PROGRAM SO I
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT THE
TIMING WILL BE, BUT I KNOW THAT
IT WILL BE COMING UP. AND SO
THAT WILL BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
STAY ON TRACK TO RECEIVE RECEIVE
THAT DATA AND INFORMATION. MY
FINAL QUESTION HAS TO DO. I FELT
WE HAD A REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
WAYS IN WHICH THE CDC IS
THINKING ABOUT NOT JUST ENGAGING
COMMUNITY BUT CONCRETIZE IN
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS.
UM THE SENATE PLAYED A MAJOR
ROLE IN MAKING SURE THAT SENATE
BILL SB 150 WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR, WHICH NOW ENSURES THAT
THERE ARE COMMUNITY BENEFITS AND
PROJECT LABOR IN PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS THAT HELPED TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT THE WAYS IN WHICH WE
ENSURE LABOR AND EQUITY
STANDARDS. IN THE GREEN SECTOR,
RIGHT, PARTICULARLY AROUND GREEN
MANUFACTURING. AND YOU KNOW I
WAS YOU. YOU SPOKE QUITE A BIT
ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH THERE IS
A DISCUSSION AROUND COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AGREEMENT, AND I WONDER
IF YOU COULD SHARE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT PROCESS, AND
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THOSE
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED BY THE
CDC. SO UM, WE NEED BENEFITS
AGREEMENTS OR SOMETHING THAT ARE
NEW TO US. THEY ARE BEING TALKED
ABOUT IN THE OFFSHORE WIND SPACE
. THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
REQUIRED THERE, BUT THERE IS AN
EMPHASIS AND DEVELOPERS ARE
STARTING TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES AND WE KNOW OF ONE
DEVELOPER WHO HAS DONE A COMMUNE
BENEFIT AGREEMENT WITH A TRIBE.
AND SO THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING. OFFSHORE WINDS AN
EXAMPLE ANOTHER WHERE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AGREEMENTS ARE REQUIRED
IS IN OUR NEW OPT IN
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS. SO I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT THIS CERTIFICATION
PROCESSES THAT, UH, WERE, UM
CITING YOU KNOW, GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS TO DETERMINE IF WE
CAN SAY THE PROJECT BUT
REQUIRING THAT THERE BE BENEFITS
TO THAT COMMUNITY THROUGH THIS
LEGALLY BINDING AGREEMENT AND
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS NOT ASSUMED THAT
MERELY BECAUSE A PROJECT IS
CITED IN AN AREA THAT THAT'S AN
AUTOMATIC BENEFIT. SO IN THE OPT
IN CERTIFICATION PROCESS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE ARE LOOKING TO DO A
LOT OF ENGAGEMENT AND WILL BE
REQUIRED TO DO WORKSHOPS WHERE
WE CAN OBTAIN INPUT FROM THE
PUBLIC, FOR EXAMPLE, ON THESE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENTS TO
SEE WHAT THEIR PERSPECTIVE IS ON
THEM ARE IS IT ACTUALLY BRINGING
VALUE TO THEM SO AGAIN. WE DON'T
WANT TO. ASSUME THAT, YOU KNOW,
MERELY HAVING A PROJECT. THERE
IS A BENEFIT, AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO BETTER ACROSS THE
BORDER AND ALL OUR PROGRAMS TO
DETERMINE HOW CAN WE FIGURE OUT
WHAT THOSE BENEFITS ARE? WHAT
TYPE OF METRICS CAN WE APPLY TO
BE ABLE TO TRACK AND MEASURE AND
HOLD OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE AND,
YOU KNOW, LOOK BACK AND, YOU
KNOW, MODIFY OUR PROCESSES IF WE
NEED TO, IF WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE COMMUNITIES FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE, IS THAT THESE? UM I
MEAN, THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING, THE ACTIONS WE'RE TAKING
THE PROJECTS ARE NOT NECESSARILY
BRINGING VALUE TO THEM. I REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT AND
PARTICULARLY AS WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOW SB 150 WILL BE APPLIED
IN PARTICULARLY THE GREEN
MANUFACTURING SPACE, THERE'S A
LOT THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM WHAT
CCS ALREADY DOING. IN THIS
PROCESS, EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN THE
EARLY STAGES, BUT THINKING ABOUT
THE EVALUATIVE PROCESS AT THE
END TO MAKE SURE THE OUTCOMES
ARE REALIZED, YES, WHEN YOU
SHARED THAT AS A PRIORITY, I
REALLY I WAS REALLY TOUCHED BY
THAT AND WANTED TO SAY I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
AGAIN AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THOSE
METRICS AS WELL, BECAUSE I THINK
WE UM WE ARE COMMITTED TO ALWAYS
IMPROVE EEN IN THERE WILL ALWAYS
BE AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT. SO UM,
I DID WANT TO TELL YOU ONE MORE
THINGS IN HER SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
I HADN'T MENTIONED TO YOU THAT,
UM THERE IS ANOTHER. YOU CAN
CONSIDER IT A MECHANISM FOR
HOLDING THIS ACCOUNTABLE ON
BENEFITS ON ALSO WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES, WHICH IS THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ADVISORY GROUP IS THE PRIMARY
ADVISORY BODY FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. THEY'RE ALSO ADVISED
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
CONSTANTLY YOU KNOW, PROVIDING
US GUIDANCE AND INPUT ON WHAT
THE ENERGY COMMISSION CAN DO
BETTER IN OUR GRANT PROGRAMS AND
ANOTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL. SO I
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE THERE ARE
GOING TO BE THREE OPENINGS. WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE MORE
REPRESENTATION FROM THE
DISTRICTS HERE AND GIVEN THE
EMPHASIS YOU MADE ON
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO GAIN
MORE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT CLEAN
ENERGY BE INVOLVED. I THINK THIS
WOULD BE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY. IF
YOU HAVE ANY CANDIDATES. WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR ABOUT THEM,
AND WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND GIVE YOU
THAT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY ADVISORY
GROUP OPENINGS ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND FOR SURE
WE'LL BE IN TOUCH. THANK YOU FOR
THAT WONDERFUL UM, BEFORE WE GO
TO SENATOR WILK ON THAT ISSUE,
UM I JUST THINK ABOUT IT, I
DON'T KNOW. OFFHAND ARE THESE
ADVISORY POSITIONS WHO
DETERMINES WHO GETS TO BE ON THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE? HAUER MAYBE
A LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT WE CAN HAVE IF THE
STAFF WILL GET IT TO OUR STAFF.
WE CAN SHARE IT WITH, UM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ABSOLUTELY
AMERICANS. WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
ALWAYS SEEKING TO HAVE A DIVERSE
GROUP AND SO COMING FROM
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE AND
WITH DIFFERENT EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE THAT WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL TO US. IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO DO THAT, THE WHO MAKES THE
SELECTIONS ARE REALLY, UM, THE
COMMISSION'S BOTH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HAS TO GO
THROUGH THEM AND IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH ENERGY COMMISSION. WE
BOTH HAVE TO APPROVE, BUT WE DO
HAVE A VERY SOLID PROCESS WHERE
WE HAVE THE YOU ARE ABLE TO
NOMINATE YOURSELF FOR THAT
OPENING. OTHER PEOPLE CAN
NOMINATE YOU FOR THAT OPENING.
OUR STAFF GOES THROUGH A PROCESS
WHERE THEY INTERVIEW THE
CANDIDATES, AND THEN THEY
PROVIDE THE COMMISSIONERS WHO
ARE THE LEADS ON THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY ADVISORY
GROUP, THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CANDIDATES AND THEN WE GO
THROUGH TO SEE WHO WOULD BE THE
BEST FIT, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
THE COHORT. WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE MISSING? THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO US. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE AREAS THAT AREN'T
BEING REPRESENTATIVE THAT WE
ALSO ALSO WANT TO HEAR AND LEARN
FROM, SO IT IS A PROCESS AND WE
CAN PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
HORRIFIC. WE WILL MAKE SURE OUR
STAFF WILL MAKE SURE TO REACH
OUT SO THAT WE CAN GET THAT AND
SHARE IT WITH OUR COLLEAGUES.
THEY'RE ALWAYS VERY INTERESTED
IN THAT KIND OF VOICE AND
REPRESENTATION AND STAKEHOLDER.
PROCESSES. SENATOR WILL. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRO TIM.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
CONFIRMATION AGAIN. I'M JUST
HERE FOR COLOR THIS AFTERNOON
COLOR, SO THAT'S GREAT CHANCE TO
ME. AND I KNOW YOU DID ME A JOB,
OKAY? SHE VERY MUCH ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATION, SO I'M GOING TO BE
REFLECTING HER VOTE TODAY. AND
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING I DO I
NOTICE THAT YOU ARE THE POINT
PERSON ON THE LITHIUM VALLEY
VISION, WHICH I'M EXCITED TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT. SO FIVE YEARS
AGO, I WAS ON A TOUR. DOWN IN
CHILE. Ó BRIEFING WITH THE
AMERICAN AMBASSADOR, AND HE WAS
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT CHINA
COMING IN AND BUYING UP ALL THE
ASSETS, INCLUDING LITHIUM, AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY RECENT YEARS
WE'VE HAD CHIP SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUE ON MYRIAD MYRIAD PRODUCTS,
OBVIOUSLY EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON THE WORLD RIGHT NOW
INCREDIBLY UNSTABLE. SO BEING
ABLE TO PRODUCE THESE THINGS
INTERNALLY IS REALLY POSITIVE
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THEY SAY
IN TERMS OF GEOPOLITICS, THAT
GEOGRAPHY IS DESTINY AND REALLY
IMPERIAL VALLEY HAS BEEN LIMITED
TO AGRICULTURE, AND NOW THEY
HAVE THIS TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
. I'M SURE YOU GUYS HAVE ALREADY
INTERFACE WITH IMPERIAL COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
I HAD A BRIEFING FROM THEM. THIS
FARM BLOWN AWAY WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING DOWN THERE, SO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY.
NOT ONLY TO PROTECT OUR NATIONAL
INTERESTS, BUT ALSO THE
TREMENDOUS ABILITY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GENERATE WEALTH
FOR CALIFORNIANS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU COULD SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT, I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. ABSOLUTELY SOME
GLAD YOU KNOW YOU RECOGNIZE THE
POTENTIAL IN THE POSSIBILITIES.
LITHIUM VALLEY ISN'T FOR SURE
THING. IT HAS A LOT OF
POSSIBILITY. BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN
BEFORE. YOU KNOW, WE CAN
ACTUALLY REALIZE IT. AND SO, UM,
ONE OF THE THINGS IS THAT THAT
AREA HAS BEEN, YOU KNOW, LEFT
BEHIND AND HAS A LOT OF
POLLUTION CONCERNS. AND SO THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT THE COMMUNITY
WANTS TO ADDRESS. SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT? WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY. I HAVE BEEN DOWN
THERE MULTIPLE TIMES. THAT'S ONE
OF THE APPROACHES THAT I TAKE TO
ENERGY IS GOING TO THE PLACES SO
I CAN GET MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE
NUANCE AND THE NEEDS. AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES AND
MEETING THE PEOPLE. SO UM, I
HAVE GONE DOWN THERE MEANT THAT
WITH THE COUNTY, THE COUNTY HAS
COME APPEAR AS WELL, WHICH HAS
BEEN FANTASTIC, AND I THINK
THERE IS ALSO OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP SUPPORT THE CITY'S THERE
WHO AREN'T AS READY AS THE
COUNTY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE, YOU
KNOW. TO MAXIMIZE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE COMING
UP, WHETHER IT BE LITHIUM VALLEY
OR, YOU KNOW OTHERS, SO I AM
TRYING TO BE VERY DILIGENT ABOUT
WORKING WITH THE CITIES OF THE
SEVEN CITIES THAT MAKE UP THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY SO THAT THEY CAN
BE READY AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE THEM TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CAPACITY AND I'M
WORKING WITH THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE SENIOR
ADVISOR ON SOCIAL INNOVATION TO
SEE IF WE CAN OBTAIN
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS TO DO MORE
PROGRAMS THERE THAT CAN GET THEM
READY. SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON.
THE OTHER THING IS, TOO IS THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF YOU KNOW,
LITHIUM VALLEY AND THE POTENTIAL
HAS BROUGHT A LOT OF ATTENTION,
VISIBILITY, ETCETERA. AND SO
THERE IS A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM
FROM A MULTITUDE OF STATE
AGENCIES TO GET INVOLVED TO
LEARN MORE AND THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN AND WHAT THEY CAN
DO THERE. AND SO ENERGY
COMMISSION IS CONVENING ALL OF
THE STATE AGENCIES WHO HAVE AN
INTEREST OR ALREADY
PARTICIPATING OR INVOLVED SO
THAT WE CAN BE MORE ORGANIZED,
COORDINATED AND HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HELPING ENSURE THAT THE LITHIUM
VALLEY VISION DOES HAPPEN AND
THAT WE HAVE A PLAN FOR IT AND
THAT WE'RE ALSO UTILIZING OUR
RESOURCES MORE EFFECTIVELY. AS A
WHOLE, SO WE HAD A FIRST MEETING
DECEMBER AND WE'RE HOPING TO DO
MORE OF THOSE MEETINGS THIS
YEAR, SO IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOU. NO ONE NEEDS TO BE
DONE. AND YOU KNOW, TAKING
ACTION IN ORDER TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THE LITHIUM VALLEY UH
HAPPENS WELL, I HOPE THAT WE'RE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT AND AGAIN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
CONFIRMATION. I DO TOO. THANK
YOU. AND I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
LITHIUM VALUE I THINK HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO TRANSFORM THE WORLD
AND HAVE CALIFORNIA BE AT THE
LEAD, YOU KNOW, SIMILAR TO WHAT
SILICON VALLEY DID FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE GLOBE, BUT I
THINK IN THIS, UM YOU KNOW, WITH
THIS OPPORTUNITY, WE CAN DO IT
IN A MORE EQUITABLE MANNER AND
HAVE IT BE MORE SUSTAINABLE. SO
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
PIECE. SENATOR THANK YOU, JUST
ALONG THE LINES BEFORE I HANDED
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR. I HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT UP. UM, ANY
IDEA ON HAMLINE FOR YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT WE CAN TAKE A LONG
TIME. I KNOW WE NEED TO DO THE
PROPER DUE DILIGENCE. WE NEED TO
CONSIDER ALL OF THE ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ALL THOSE
IMPACTS. JUST I WON'T HOLD YOU
TO IT HERE ANYWAY, TO HOLD YOU
TO IT. JUST THOUGHTS ON
FUTURISTIC. THANK YOU. FOR
AMERICANS. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
. WE WERE THINKING ABOUT THAT,
TOO. I THINK THE FIRST MILESTONE
WE HAVE TO HIT IS FOR THE
LITHIUM DEVELOPERS TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE AT MASS. CAL, AND WE
THINK THAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS, AND ONCE
THEY ARE ABLE TO PRODUCE A MASS
SCALE, THEN THAT MEANS THERE CAN
BE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR UM,
YOU KNOW, MANUFACTURERS OF
BATTERY COMPONENTS MADE
BATTERIES THEMSELVES TO START,
UM, CO LOCATING THERE AND REALLY
TURNING THAT INTO AN ECOSYSTEM
WHERE WE HAVE ALL OF IT
HAPPENING IN ONE PLACE. IT'S
CREATING A COMMUNITY LOOKING AT
THE ECONOMIC POSSIBILITIES. AND
THEN THERE WILL PROBABLY BE ALL
THE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL STUFF.
ABSOLUTELY AND YOU KNOW, WE DO
HAVE THE OPTION CERTIFICATION
PROCESS, WHICH IS AVAILABLE AS A
PATHWAY, INCLUDING FOR, UM
MANUFACTURING AND ASSEMBLY. SO
THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY AND I KNOW
THE COUNTY IS BUILDING UP THEIR
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE
PERMITTING AS WELL FOR WHAT'S
COMING, SO WE DON'T HAVE A
TIMELINE. WE'RE HOPING THAT
HAPPENS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. BUT
WE'RE YOU KNOW, WAITING FOR THAT
MAJOR MILESTONE OF THE MASS
PRODUCTION TO BE ABLE TO OCCUR.
I'M SORRY, SENATOR. BUT THIS IS
A NEW KIND OF ARENA FOR US, SO
IT IS. GOVERNMENT TYPICALLY DOES
NOT. UM YOU KNOW, FOR REASONS I
UNDERSTAND, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
BEFORE WE CAN. I MEAN, EVEN THE
OPT IN, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A NEW
ENDEAVOR, SO IT'S PROBABLY GOING
TO BE A LENGTHY PROCESS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS. YES I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT. THERE'S A
LOT OF ENTHUSIASM, BUT THERE
NEEDS TO BE THE PLANNING. SO YOU
KNOW WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT IT. I
THINK CONVENING THE STATE
AGENCIES WILL GIVE US A BETTER
SENSE OF WHERE WE'RE AT. WE ALSO
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAD
SUPPORTED THE LITHIUM VALLEY
COMMISSION, WHICH WAS A FORUM
FOR PEOPLE WHO WERE UM, UM,
INTERESTED IN LITHIUM VALLEY
BEING ABLE TO SERVE IN ME? YOU
KNOW THIS COMMISSION AND TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT WAS NEEDED,
YOU KNOW, HELPING PLAN AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PRIORITIES
WERE SO DELICIOUS VALLEY
COMMISSION SET OUT ABOUT 15
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BRING BACK TO THE TABLE
THROUGH A SYMPOSIUM THAT WE'RE
HOLDING MARCH 8TH, AND SO IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. IT'S ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO DO OUR BEST TO MOVE THINGS
ALONG AND ALONG IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU'RE HIGHLIGHTING THE PLANNING
, FIGURING OUT WHAT THE
RESOURCES ARE, BECAUSE THERE IS
A LOT OF NEED IN THAT AREA, AND
THERE'S A MAJOR LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE, SO IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN AS QUICKLY AS
SILICON VALLEY DID. THIS WILL
WILL TAKE LONGER AND WE'LL NEED
SOME DEEP INVESTMENT. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS WE'RE DOING IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN
LEVERAGE THE OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW, WITH THE FEDERAL
FUNDING AS WELL. SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY IS, YOU
KNOW, HAS POTS OF MONEY. WE DID
A VISIT. WE ORGANIZED A VISIT
FOR MEMBERS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AND FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE. THEY CAME TO THE
LITHIUM VALLEY AND I THINK THAT
WAS REALLY HELPFUL IN THEM.
SCENE WITH THE POSSIBILITIES
WERE AND THE REALITIES AND SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOME
INVESTMENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY AS WELL. AND WE'RE
GOING TO NEED THAT. I THINK.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
CLEARLY NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT'S
ALREADY EXISTING IN TERMS OF
THIS, BUT I THANK YOU FOR
SENDING ME IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE INDULGENCE. ABSOLUTELY MADAM
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, MADAM.
PERTINENT AND FRANKLY, I THINK I
SPEAK FOR EVERYBODY ON THE DIETS
THAT YOU CAN CUT IN FRONT OF
ANYBODY UP HERE. OH, RIGHT.
THANK YOU. VERY GRACIOUS. IT WAS
A PLEASURE TO VISIT WITH YOU
YESTERDAY. I THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME THAT YOU GAVE ME. I AM I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE SENATE
PRO TEM AND SENATOR WILKES
QUESTIONS ON THE LITHIUM ISSUE
IS HAVING, UH NOT CHECKS AND
BALANCES BUT HAVING A PROCESS IN
PLACEMENT TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS, I SUGGEST YOU REACH OUT TO
LORELEI OVER YET, UM, I THINK
EVERYBODY KNOWS HER NAME, AND I
THINK THAT SHE HAS OUT OF THE
BOX THINKING SHE'S ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH IMPERIAL COUNTY.
NOW THAT I KNOW OF, AND THEN
ALSO DOING THOSE PROJECTS IN
KERN COUNTY, WHETHER IT'S BORON,
SEARLES VALLEY MINERALS OR
OTHERS. BECAUSE I DO AGREE. WE
NEED TO TAKE THIS FROM CHINA AND
HARVEST THIS THIS AMAZING
PRODUCT THAT WE HAVE HERE AND SO
I THINK SHE HAS A BLUEPRINT A
PLAN AND SHE'S DONE SOME ER
STUDIES AND SHE'D BE VERY
VALUABLE TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS KNOW WHO SHE
IS. YES JUST THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT. I APPRECIATE ALL THE
HELP WE CAN GET, ESPECIALLY FROM
EXPERTS WITH EXPERIENCE. NO NO
PROBLEM AT ALL TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE WORKFORCE. UH, THE WORK FOR
QUESTIONS THAT MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES WAS ASKING, UM
YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DEAD SET ON ELIMINATING AN
INDUSTRY THAT PROVIDES THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY, WHICH 70%
OF IT IS PRODUCED IN CURRENT
COUNTY, AND, UM. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE WORKFORCE IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY, IT'S 55% PEOPLE OF
COLOR. IT'S 6.5% WOMEN. IT'S 18%
VETERAN AND IT'S 30% 2ND
CHANCERS, SO INDIVIDUALS WHO
COME OUT OF A PRISON SYSTEM THAT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED AND MAKE 100 SOMETHING
$1000 A YEAR WHERE THEY COULDN'T
DO THAT IN ANY MOST JOB OR ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY, SO I THINK YOU
HAVE A READY WORKFORCE. AS
PEOPLE ARE BEING LAID OFF,
CONTINUALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET PERMITS. SO IF
YOU HAVE JOBS AVAILABLE, I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO OFFER THOSE JOBS TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
WORKED YEARS IN THE OIL INDUSTRY
THAT NOW FIND THEMSELVES BEING
RECRUITED BY OUR OIL COMPANIES
TO GO TO VENEZUELA TO HARVEST
THE OIL THAT WE USE EVERY SINGLE
DAY. I GOT A JOB OUT ON IT JUST
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO. JUST FOOD
FOR THOUGHT. YES SENATOR GROVER.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
I THINK THE YOU KNOW WORKERS
FROM YOUR AREA OR ARE GOING TO
BE NEEDED. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL, AND THEY HAVE THE
TYPES OF SKILLS THAT CAN
TRANSFER AND I THINK I DON'T
LOOK AT IT AS A TRANSITION.
NECESSARILY I LOOK AT IT MORE AS
AN EVOLUTION WHERE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE AWARENESS ABOUT WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. EDUCATION AND
TRAINING ABOUT ME, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE WHAT HAS TO BE SHIFTED AND
WHERE THOSE SKILLS THAT THEY DO
HAVE CAN BE APPLIED. AND SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING IT FORWARD. THAT WAY. I
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL FOR UM THE SUCCESS OF
YOU KNOW ANY CLEAN ENERGY
MOVEMENT THAT WE HAVE. I
APPRECIATE THAT SIDE NOTE.
THEY'RE BEING LAID OFF AND HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF FOR THE LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE HOUSE PAYMENTS, CAR
PAYMENTS. SO YES, THIS HAS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT MOVES FORWARD
BECAUSE WE ARE LOSING THEM IN
DROVES TO LIKE I SAID, I JUST
GOT AN AD ACROSS MY PHONE ABOUT
A MAJOR OIL COMPANY WANTING TO
GET PEOPLE TO GO TO VENEZUELA,
AND THEY'LL PAY FOR STUFF. TO
PRODUCE OIL FOR US THAT WE USE
HERE. VENEZUELA NO DOUBT I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. AND WE DID
TALK ABOUT THIS. AND I REALLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND, UM
I APPRECIATE YOU SPENDING TIME
WITH ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS THAT
HAPPENED TO BE IN THE OFFICE
RIGHT BEFORE YOU CAME IN. YES
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZED YOU AND
YOU HAD GIVEN THEM THE KINDNESS
TO LISTEN TO THEIR ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE AGAIN DEALING WITH
CARBON EMISSIONS AND GETTING OFF
OF COAL PRODUCTION AND MOVING
INTO A PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF RED
RESTORATION THEY HAVE TO DO TO
THEIR PLANT TO MAKE THINGS
FUNCTIONAL, BUT I DO BELIEVE
IT'S THE ONLY ONE IN NORTH
AMERICA, SO WE NEED TO KEEP IT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. UM I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DO ALL THAT I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT SBX ONE TO WHICH WE DID
TALK ABOUT YESTERDAY. UM I DID
MENTION TO YOU AND I HAD STAFF
RESEARCH AND FINDING OUT THE
EXACT VERBIAGE AND PULL UP THE
VIDEO. UM THE SPX 20 WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO APPLY TO OIL
EXTRACTORS. BECAUSE THIS IS A.
UM BLANKET GOING TO FIND WHERE
PRICE GOUGING ARE SUPPOSED PRICE
GOUGING IS TAKING PLACE ON THE
COST FOR FUEL. AND UM, I TRIED
TO EXPLAIN DURING THE HEARING
THAT WE HAD WITH MS SANCHEZ FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AT THE
HEARING. MY DIRECT QUESTION WAS
TO HER WAS TO CLARIFY WHAT THE
INTENT IS BECAUSE OIL EXTRACTORS
OR OIL PRODUCERS ARE PRICE
TAKERS. THE PRICE IS SET ON A
GLOBAL MARKET. OUR CURRENT
COUNTY OIL EXTRACTORS OR
PRODUCERS HAVE TO SELL IT FOR
WHAT THAT PRICE IS, WHETHER IT'S
$20 A BARREL OR $120 A BARREL.
THEY DON'T GET TO SET THEIR OWN
PRICE. AND SO WHEN I ASKED THE
QUESTION TO MS SANCHEZ AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IF THIS WAS
THEIR INTENT, SHE SAID, I QUOTE
QUOTE. WE WILL CLARIFY THIS AND
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE AND STAFF. THIS BILL IS A
DOWNSTREAM OF EXTRACTION OF OIL.
SO BELOW THE OIL EXTRACTOR, WHO
HAS NO CONTROL OVER THE PRICE
GAME. WE TALKED ABOUT JOBBERS.
WE TALKED ABOUT DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS ON HOW TO TRANSPORT
OIL. TURN IT INTO FUEL REFINING
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO, UM I JUST,
UH ON A REGULATORY PROCESS. I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT WHAT'S
IN. THERE'S NOT A LEGISLATIVE
FIX. WE TRIED TO WORK ON A
LEGISLATIVE FIX TO CONFIRM WHAT
THE GOVERNORS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID DURING THAT
HEARING, AND NOW IT'S IN YOUR
TERRITORY IS THE C E. C DO YOU
SEE THAT EXTRACTORS WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPORTING AND
ALL THIS STUFF? UM EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WITH
THE PRICE IS SET OUT. SO UH, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE HAD AND YOU WERE
HELPING EDUCATE ME AS WELL IN
THIS ARENA BECAUSE IT IS, YOU
KNOW, NEW TO ALL OF US, AND SO
I'M TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND IT. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I FOUND OUT DURING MY
RESEARCH TO GET THAT INFORMATION
WAS THAT THE POTENTIAL PENALTY.
AH! UH THAT ONLY APPLIES TO
REFINERS. SO PRODUCERS UM, WHO
WERE YOU ARE SAYING ARE PRICE
TAKERS ARE EXEMPTED FROM THAT
PENALTY. SO YOU ARE CORRECT, AND
IT BELIEVE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
MISS SANCHEZ IS THAT SHE SAID IT
DIDN'T APPLY. AND IT DOES NOT
FROM WHAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS IN
THE RESEARCH RESEARCH I DID AND
VALIDATED IT WITH THEM WITH
STAFF. THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF
YOU COULD FOLLOW UP WITH ME AND
WRITING ON THAT BECAUSE THERE
STILL IS A HUGE CONCERN THAT
THESE, UM THESE EXTRACTORS OR
PRODUCERS, PRODUCERS THAT
ADMINISTRATION COSTS THESE
PRODUCERS, LIKE I SAID THEY ARE
PRICE TAKERS, BUT THEY'RE
WRAPPED UP IN THIS LEGISLATION,
AND THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
WHAT THEIR PRICES. HMM. AND THEY
SHOULDN'T BE IN THIS
LEGISLATION, BUT THEY'RE DOING
HUGE AMOUNTS OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO TELL YOU NOW THE
CEO THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
WRAPPED UP IN THIS SITUATION. I
THINK YOU ARE RIGHT. YEAH THERE
THEY THE THEY ARE FACING THOSE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO THEY
WILL HAVE TO PROVIDE DATA, BUT
THEY WON'T BE IMPACTED BY A
PENALTY. AND, UM, I THINK ONE OF
THE LESSONS I LEARNED IN
DIALOGUING WITH WITH YOU ABOUT
THIS IS THAT THIS AREA IS
COMPLEX, AND I THINK WE NEED TO
DO SOME MORE AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION ON THIS, INCLUDING FOR
YOU KNOW, ESPECIALLY FOR FOLKS
WHO DON'T AND, YOU KNOW, GET
INVOLVED SO DEEPLY ON ENERGY
ISSUES. I MEAN, YOU AND I HAVE
AND WE STILL YOU KNOW, ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
WHAT? SO I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE MORE
CLEAR ABOUT WHO IS AFFECTED AND
WHO IS NOT. BUT THE THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. YEAH, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT UNDERSTANDING.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD FOR
YEARS NOW, SINCE WHEN IT PASSED
AUGUST, SO NOT A YEAR SORRY,
BUT, UM AGAIN. UM THE INTENT OF
THE BILL WAS TO AFFECT
DOWNSTREAM MEANING BELOW THE
EXTRACTOR, HMM. AND BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE COST UH, ARE
MAINLY UH HUH. VARIABLE THE
VARIABLE COST AND HOW MUCH YOU
PAY YOUR STAFF. YOUR DRIVER'S
YOUR TRANSPORTATION PEOPLE. THE
REFINERY COSTS THAT'S ALL VARIED
. THE EXTRACTOR. THE PRODUCER IS
SET AND THEY DON'T THEY'RE NOT
THE BAD GUY. UM AND I'M NOT
SEEING ANYBODY ELSE IS THE BAD
GUY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. I HAVE A QUESTION
. I WANT TO FOLLOW UP THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY IS, UM
SEE. SEE NOW BECAUSE I REALIZED
THAT THIS IS A BRAND NEW
POSITION. BRAND NEW COMMITTEE.
YOU'RE JUST GETTING IT STARTED.
YOU HAVE HIRED AN INCREDIBLE
PERSON. YOU SAID YES TO RUN THE
DIVISION, BUT YOU'RE STILL
STAFFING IT UP. I THINK THEY'RE
ALLOWED SIX POSITIONS AND YOU
SAID HE HAS ONE HIMSELF. UM SO I
REALIZED THAT WE'RE IN THE BRAND
NEW STAGES OF, UM HMM. I HAVE A
QUESTION ON THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE. UM. ON THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. WHAT'S THE, UM. WHAT
IS THE I FEEL LIKE THIS IS GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS REFINERY
THING. OBVIOUSLY WITH THE BILL
THAT WAS PASSED. AND YES, YOU
NOW HAVE THE AUTHORITY AS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DETERMINE WHEN AND WHEN NOT
REFINERS CAN, UM, SHUT DOWN AND
DO MAINTENANCE. THEY COME
SHUTDOWNS RIGHT BECAUSE THEY HAD
DONE THE ENTIRE PLANT BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T HAVE CERTAIN THINGS
OPERATING. WHEN YOU'VE GOT
CERTAIN THINGS NOT OPERATING, SO
IT'S SHUT DOWN THE PLANT AND DO
MAINTENANCE. YOU THE, BUT THE
CEO IS NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
SCHEDULING OR APPROVING THE
SCHEDULING OF THAT MAINTENANCE.
I ASKED YOU YESTERDAY ABOUT
ABOUT A LIABILITY ISSUE. IF A
REFINER COMES TO YOU, AND NOT
YOU BUT THE SEED AND SAYS, YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO SHUT DOWN. WE
THINK THERE'S EXPOSURE HERE. WE
HAVE TO FIX THIS. WE HAVE A
MAINTENANCE PROBLEM, AND THE CEO
SAYS NO. BECAUSE ABC REFINERIES
SHUTTING DOWN WHICH WOULD YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY CAUSE A SUPPLY
AND DEMAND ISSUE AND CAUSE
PRICES TO GO UP AND THERE IS A
LIABILITY EXPOSURE OF AN
EXPLOSION OR SOMETHING HAPPENS.
WITH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY, THE
EMPLOYEES OR THE FACILITIES OR
THE CITIES AROUND THESE
REFINERIES. IS THAT LIABILITY?
WHERE IS THAT GOING TO FALL IS
GOING TO FALL IN THE IN THE
STATE, OR DO YOU ANTICIPATE IT
FALLING ON THE REFINER WHO HAD
NO CONTROL OVER THE SHUTDOWN OR
NOT BEING ALLOWED TO HAVE THE
SHUTDOWN? TO FIX THE MAINTENANCE
PROBLEM. I THINK THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION, AND I WILL
LOOK INTO THAT ONE DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE TO DO THAT. SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT I DON'T HAVE MORE
ANSWERS. NOW HOW I DO KNOW THAT
ONE OF OUR RESPONSIBILITIES IS
THAT LONG TERM PLANNING THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO? AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF IT FALLS UNDER
THAT WE ALL ARE ALSO FOCUSED ON
GATHERING THE DATA THAT WE NEED
TO, UM, HELP US DETERMINE WHAT
IS HAPPENING AT THE PUMP. AND
THEN ALSO DETERMINING YOU KNOW
THAT PENALTY AND THEY DO KNOW
THAT STAFF IS WORKING REALLY
HARD ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN GATHERING. A LOT
OF INFORMATION ARE STARTING TO
SEE SOME TRENDS. BUT UM, AREN'T
AT THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE READY
TO MAKE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
I SAY THAT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
SURE IF YOU KNOW, THOSE WOULD BE
THE TYPE OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE QUESTION THAT
YOU'RE ASKING, SO I'LL LOOK
FURTHER INTO THAT YOU DID BRING
UP THE COMMITTEE, SO THERE IS AN
INDEPENDENT CONSUMER FUELS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT HASN'T
BEEN FULLY FORMED. THERE'S GOING
TO BE EIGHT MEMBERS, UM PROTO
AMERICANS SPEAKER RIVAS HAVE
EACH APPOINTED A MEMBER, SO
THERE'S AT LEAST TWO ON THAT
COMMITTEE. AND THEN, UM, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY
GUIDANCE FROM THIS COMMUNITY IS
STILL NOT FORMED. BUT
POTENTIALLY, THAT MAY BE A PLACE
A FORUM AS WELL WHERE WE'RE
GETTING SOME OF THAT GUIDANCE
AND INPUT SO WE WILL HAVE MORE
MOVEMENT THERE, AND I CAN ALSO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT
PIECE. THAT'S IN THE CONNECTIONS
. THANK YOU, AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DIVE INTO THIS ISSUE. I DO. IT'S
IMPORTANT. I THINK IT'S A YOU
KNOW, VITAL CONSUMER PROTECTION
MATTER, YOU KNOW. PEOPLE YOU
KNOW, ARE GOING TO THE PUMP AND
IF THERE ARE PRICE HIKES
HAPPENING, OR IF THE GAS IS MORE
EXPENSIVE, YOU KNOW ONE DAY THEN
IT WAS THE OTHER DAY THAT
MATTERS TO PEOPLE AND THAT CAN
IMPACT. YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO, UM, YOU KNOW, PUT YOU
KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE ABLE TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE OR THEY CAN
PAY THEIR ELECTRICITY BILL LIKE
IT IMPACTS THEM, SO I THINK IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET IN.
SO I DIG INTO THIS AND I AM
TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD AROUND
ALL OF IT. SO I WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU, SENATOR. THINK YOU'RE
ASKING VERY VITAL QUESTION.
LEAVE YOU 100% BASED ON THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD. I'D REALLY
LIKE YOU DID ON VESSEL FINDER
TO. WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT. WHERE FOREIGN OPERATORS
ARE BRINGING US OIL AND THEY
KIND OF JUST CIRCLE OUTSIDE OUR
PORTS. UM AND WAIT FOR THE PRICE
TO GO UP, AND THEN THEY BRING
FUEL IN IF YOU CAN TRACK THEM
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING, AND THEY'RE
FOREIGN OPERATORS. BUT IF YOU
GREAT MORE MONEY ON EVERY GALLON
OF GAS, OR THAT'S ON THERE, AND
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GALLONS, IT'S A
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT COST BENEFIT
TO THEM TO DO THAT, BUT IT'S
DETRIMENTAL TO US. MHM COMMITTEE
YOU JUST MENTIONED IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE EMPIRE'S ARY COMMITTEE.
OR IS THAT THE SAME COMMITTEE? I
THINK THAT WAS THE SAME ONE?
THERE'S ONE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
OR RELATED TO SPX 12. OKAY SO
THAT ON THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT SET UP AND
I KNOW THIS IS ALL BRAND NEW,
BUT I WANT I'M TRYING TO SET THE
STAGE FOR HOW WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE, AND YOU HAVE BEEN SO
REASONABLE AND SO I'D LIKE YOU
HAVE RESEARCH STAFF YOU'VE
BROUGHT. YOU KNOW TODAY YOU GOT
ME INFORMATION THAT I DIDN'T
HAVE YESTERDAY. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. UM I KNOW YOU'RE MOVING
FORWARD ALREADY. THE WHEN I SEE
YOU AGAIN IS PROPOSING A MARGIN
CAP FOR PENALTIES, AND IT'S
SUPPOSED TO START AT THE END OF
2024. BUT WE'RE IN JANUARY AND I
REALIZED WE HAVE THE INTO ALL
THIS STARTS. WE DON'T HAVE A
COMMITTEE SET UP YET. UM SO I
HAVE CONCERNS THAT YOU KNOW, THE
C E C IS MOVING FORWARD WITH A
MARGIN CAP ON PROFITABILITY FOR
EVERY BARREL OF OIL FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND, BUT THERE'S NO
COMMITTEE DOING THE
INVESTIGATION READING THE DATA
TO FIND OUT YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ISSUE IS AND FULL DISCLOSURE. I
DO BELIEVE THAT EVERY STEP HAS
BEEN TAKEN TO DERAIL THE OIL
INDUSTRY LIKE LIVERMORE LABS AND
APPROVAL ON FRACKING AND ALL
THESE TESTING THAT ALL COME
BACK, YOU KNOW, LIKE IT'S NOT
THE OIL COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
SOMETHING WRONG. UM I THINK THIS
WILL SHOW THAT AS WELL. I HAVE
VERY I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT
THIS WILL SHOW THAT AS WELL. BUT
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS, IS THAT
HOW DO YOU MOVE FORWARD ON AN
INDUSTRY? KAPPA KAPPA FOR A
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY ON
PROFITABILITY WHEN THERE IS NOT
A DATA OR COMMITTEE THAT'S
PUTTING IT TOGETHER TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION TO SHOW THAT IS
EVEN NECESSARY. YEAH, AND I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
SO AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND ON
THIS STAFF ISN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATION ON THE PENALTY
YET THEY'RE STILL DOING A LOT OF
DATA GATHERING. SO I THINK IT IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME. SO IT
IS VERY POSSIBLE THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY BE FORMED BEFORE
THEN, AND I HAVE LEARNED AS WELL
THAT UH, OR ENERGY COMMISSION IS
WORKING ON SETTING UP, YOU KNOW,
LIKE ROLES IN GOVERNANCE AND
PROVIDING MORE MATERIAL ON HOW
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD BE SET UP,
AND I THINK THAT WILL HELP MOVE
IT FORWARD. AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS TO THAT OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WOULD ACTUALLY BE, UM,
AT THE FOREFRONT OF MAKING, UM
ALL THIS, YOU KNOW ADVANCE, SO I
THINK THAT TO ME SHOWS THAT IT
WILL MOVE AND WE MAY HAVE THAT
COMMITTEE SET UP SO THAT IT
ALIGNS, YOU KNOW, WITH THE OTHER
PROCESSES THAT ARE HAPPENING. I
APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR TIME. I
APPRECIATE YOU DIVING INTO THE
CEREALS, VALLEY MINERALS ISSUES.
I HAVE SHE ATE YOU. I DO. I
APPRECIATE YOU YESTERDAY, WHEN I
WAS ASKING YOU THESE QUESTIONS.
IT WAS LIKE A WE WERE IN CLASS
TOGETHER, RIGHT? YES I DON'T
MEAN NEGATIVELY. BUT YOU KNOW,
IN A GOOD WAY, I AGREE. WE DID
THIS. THIS THIS. THIS IS WHAT I
FOUND OUT, AND, UM NORMALLY,
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING APPOINTED
TO YOUR POSITION. I DON'T MEAN
NORMALLY, BUT THEY DON'T. THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE TO WRITE. BUT
YOU DID. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT. THANK YOU,
MA'AM. WELL I APPRECIATE YOU
RECOGNIZING THAT AND I DID WANT
TO TELL YOU, SENATOR GROVE AND I
ALSO WANTED TO GIVE SOME PRAISE
TO PROTO MADKINS THAT ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF GOING TO MEET WITH
YOU WAS THAT YOU HAD THE LITTLE
ENGINE THAT COULD BOOK OUT IN
THE LOBBY AREA. AND YOU
EXPLAINED HOW, UM, THE TÂM
ATKINS AND YOU SUPPORTED AND
THIS DOLLY PARTON IMAGINATION
LIBRARY PROGRAM, AND I THOUGHT
IT WAS WONDERFUL AND THE LITTLE
ENGINE THAT COULD HAS BEEN ONE
OF MY FAVORITE BOOKS. UM, AND IT
REALLY RESONATED WITH ME AS A
KID, BUT I DIDN'T REALIZE UNTIL
LATER WHY, AND IT YOU KNOW, JUST
HELPED ME REFLECT YESTERDAY
ABOUT HOW THAT MESSAGE OF I
THINK I CAN IS SO IMPORTANT AND
EVEN IN MY ENERGY WORK, I HAVE
THAT MESSAGE RUNNING THROUGH MY
HEAD, ESPECIALLY WHEN I YOU
KNOW, HAVE THE CHALLENGES. AGES
OF BEING FRUSTRATED THAT I DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION THAT SOMEONE IS
ASKING ME FOR THAT SOMEONE NEEDS
AND SO I, YOU KNOW, DO FUNCTION
THAT WAY WHERE I DO WANT TO
OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION, AND I
DON'T LET THAT STOP ME AND I DO
WANT TO PROVIDE SOLUTIONS FOR
COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
NEED. JUST LIKE THE LITTLE
ENGINE, YOU KNOW, HELPED OUT
THOSE FOLKS. SO THERE WAS THERE
WAS A I REALLY ENJOYED MY TIME
WITH YOU. AND YOU KNOW, EVEN
STARTING OUT WITH JUST SEEING
THOSE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'RE SUPPORTING ARE VERY
HELPFUL, SO I ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HOPEFULLY HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT WAS A
GREAT HONOR TO WORK WITH THE PRO
TIM ON THAT AND IT HOPEFULLY IT
FOSTERS A LEVER READING FOR OUR
YOUNG KIDS THAT ABSOLUTELY
BEFORE THEY GO TO SCHOOL, AND I
CAN TELL YOU IN CURRENT COUNTY
WE'VE ALREADY SIGNED UP
6000/6000 KIDS, AND I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE. IT'S
EXCELLENT. I'M GONNA I'M GOING
TO LOOK TO SEE IF IT'S AVAILABLE
AT MY KIDS SCHOOL. UNFORTUNATELY
THEY'RE BOTH AGED OUT. BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW THE OTHER KIDS
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT. THANK
YOU, MA'AM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS I TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR LAIRD. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE MAKE ONE COMMENT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND FOR AH, THE
PUBLIC THE APPOINTMENT THAT YOU
MADE REFERENCE THAT SPEAKER THE
SPEAKER MADE TO THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. UM THE SENATE IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. IT'S THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE THAT
MAKES THOSE APPOINTMENTS. I MAY
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION. BUT
SOMETIMES MY COLLEAGUES MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN THE THEN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE ONLY REASON I
MENTIONED THAT IS BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT MY COLLEAGUES TO
SOMEHOW THINK WHAT APPOINTMENT?
WE VOTE ON THOSE, AND WE'VE DONE
THAT. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
APOLOGIZE, MISUNDERSTOOD IN THE
WORLD KNOWS THE DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS WAS SPEAKER. I GOT TO MAKE
THOSE APPOINTMENTS DIRECTLY. NOW
WE GO THROUGH OUR RULES
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE, WHICH
I'M PLEASED TO DO, AND WE GET
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS FROM MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES. UM ON ON
THESE APPOINTMENTS THAT WE GET
TO MAKE THAT GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR EDUCATING ME ON THAT SENATOR
LAIRD. YOU KNOW, IT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
YOUR CHILDREN AND STEP CHILD
HERE AND NOT ONLY YOU KNOW, I
REALIZED AS WE REFLECTED ON HOW
WELL BEHAVED THEY ARE THAT WE
SHOULD ALSO TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY GET TO SEE GOVERNMENT
INACTION. AND WHAT A WONDERFUL
THING IT IS. THEY GET TO SEE
THEIR MOM OR STEPMOM BEING
CONFIRMED, AND THAT'S A BIG
DEAL. WELL AND THEY'RE ALSO GOOD
. THERE. ALSO WELL BEHAVED,
SENATOR LAIRD. WELL, YOU. HAD
THAT EXCHANGE ABOUT THE
APPOINTMENTS WITH THE ONLY
PERSON IN MODERN TIMES THAT'S
BEEN THE SPEAKER AND THE
PROTESTS SO SHE KNOWS HOW THEY
VERY WELL. AND EVEN THOUGH YOU
GAVE A LOT OF CREDIT TO THE
LIBRARY SIDE OF IT, I THINK THE
DOLLY PARTON LINK THAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THAT,
ABSOLUTELY AND SENATOR GROVE.
IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE EVERYBODY
TALKED ABOUT ALL THE ISSUES AND
THEY DIDN'T LEAVE ME MUCH. AND
SENATOR GROVE GAVE ME A GREAT
IDEA. MHM BECAUSE THE ACCIDENT
OF HAVING HER HAVE A CONSTITUENT
IN THE OFFICE MEANS THAT MAYBE
SOME OF US SHOULD DELIBERATELY
DO THAT IN THE FUTURE. I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. I MIGHT
ACTUALLY ORGANIZED TO HAVE IT.
SHE HAD A DOZEN ACCIDENT. SHE
HAS GIVEN ME A GOOD IDEA. THAT
WAS A LUCKY I WAS NOT KIDDING.
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALKED YESTERDAY
, HMM. WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
LITHIUM VALLEY AND APPARENTLY
THE PRO TEM WAS CHANNELING THE
END OF THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE
I ACTUALLY SAID I WAS GOING TO
ASK YOU HOW IT WAS GOING TO TURN
FROM BEING ASPIRATIONAL TO
ACTUALLY BEING ON THE GROUND AND
A REAL PROGRAM AND MOVING ON IT.
IN MY COLLEAGUES DID A GREAT JOB
OF EVENT. I ASKED YOU HOW YOU
WERE GOING TO PRIORITIZE THE
MILLION DOLLARS OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY MONEY THAT'S IN THE
DIABLO CANYON DEAL. AND THEN
TODAY, THE GOVERNOR IN HIS
BUDGET STUCK WITH 100 MILLION
AND TOOK THE 900 MILLION UN
APPROPRIATED AND IT'S GOING TO
SPREAD IT OVER THREE FUTURE
YEARS. SO YOU WON'T HAVE THAT
MHM SOON. I ASKED YOU ABOUT
OFFSHORE WIND. HE DIFFERED ALL
THOSE DECISIONS TO THE MAY UH,
REVISED AND I ASKED YOU ABOUT
SPENDING THEIR CLIMATE MONEY,
AND THEN HE RECOMMENDED MOST OF
MOST OF IT AND ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION IN THE BUDGET, SO THE
THINGS THAT EITHER BEEN TALKED
ABOUT IN THE HEARING, OR WE
TALKED ABOUT ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
ONE GOT ADDRESSED AND THE FORMS
ONE OTHER THING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT DIDN'T THAT I THOUGHT
I WOULD ASK YOU IS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT HOW MUCH BATTERY
STORAGE HAS COME ONLINE IN THE
LAST YEAR, AND THAT THE LITTLE
KNOWN STORY OR LITTLE WRITTEN
STORY ABOUT THE HOT DAY IN
SEPTEMBER A YEAR AGO IS THAT FOR
A FEW HOURS, BATTERY STORAGE,
PUT MORE ENERGY ON THE GRID AND
THE BASE LOAD FROM TABLEAU,
KANYE THAT BATTERY STORAGE
HELPED BRIDGE US IN A FEW KEY
HOURS AND THE ENERGY COMMISSION
ALONG WITH SOME OTHER AGENCIES,
BUT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
DECIDES SORT OF WHAT? YOU'RE
PUSHING FOR ENERGY TO COME ON
THE GRID TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
RELIABILITY. AND A LOT OF
BATTERY STORAGE. JUST COME ON
JUST IN THE 15TH MONTH SINCE
THAT ONE DAY. AND SO MY QUESTION
YESTERDAY WHEN WE MET AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR HER MONDAY FOR
SPENDING THE TIME. WAS HOW DOES
THE ENERGY COMMISSION MAKE
ASSESSMENTS ABOUT WHAT COMES
ONLINE AND WHAT IS NEEDED AND
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE PROGRESS IN
SORT OF PUTTING ENERGY ON THE
GRID? THAT MEANS THAT EITHER
AHEAD OF WHERE WE ARE BEHIND. WE
SHOULD DO OTHER THINGS. HOW DO
YOU JUST SORT OF MOVE WITH THE
TIMES AS AS AS THE THINGS THAT
YOU WORK ON, OR ACTUALLY
SUCCESSFUL AND SORT OF COME
ONLINE? HMM THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION, SENATOR LAIRD. I
APPRECIATE THAT, SO I WILL
UPLIFT HERE. UM THE LEADERSHIP
OF VICE CHAIR CIVIL GUNDA. HE IS
THE LEAD ON RELIABILITY AND HAS
BEEN SO STRONG AND HELPFUL AND
BEEN A MENTOR TO ME. AND, UM AND
UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THIS, AND
SO, UM, I THINK THAT THE ONE OF
THE MAIN FORUMS WHERE WE DO
THOSE TYPES OF ASSESSMENTS IS
THROUGH THE SP 100 PROCEEDING.
HE DOES LEAD, SO THAT'S YOU
KNOW, WE HAD A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT IN 2021, INDICATING WHAT
TYPES OF, UM, BUILDUPS WE'RE
GOING TO NEED AND THEIR
UNPRECEDENTED UM, IN ORDER TO
GET TO OUR 100% CLEAN ENERGY
GOAL, AND THEN UM, ANOTHER AREA
WHERE WE HAVE A FORM TO BE ABLE
TO ASSESS IS THROUGH THE
INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY REPORT,
WHICH WE ARE DON'T HAVE TO DO ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS, BUT WE DO AND
SO WE SEE THOSE FORECASTS AND
THEN THAT INFORMATION IS USED BY
OUR PERIOD AGENCY, THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR THEIR
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN. SO
THAT YOU KNOW, COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR AGENCIES IS REALLY
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF THAT
PLANNING AND IDENTIFYING WHAT
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT AND
TRANSMISSION NEEDS WE HAVE OVER.
YOU KNOW THE NEXT 15 YEARS OR SO
. SO I THINK THERE'S THESE
VARIOUS FORMS WHERE WE CAN DO
THAT. UM AND THEN, UH, I KNOW
THAT OUR STAFF IS ASSESSING THE
GAS FLEETS ALL THE TIME AND
GATHERING DATA AND LOOKING
THROUGH IT. SO WE'RE ALWAYS YOU
KNOW, RECEPTIVE TO NEW
INFORMATION AND FIGURE ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THAT. AFTER
A CONVERSATION I DID LOOK AT
ENERGY STORAGE AND IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBERS, AND SO I FOUND OUT
SOME GOOD INFORMATION. IT'S KIND
OF WHAT YOU'RE LEADING TO. SO
ARE 2021. SB 100 REPORT
PROJECTED THE NEED FOR OVER 50
GIGAWATTS OF STORAGE BY 2045,
WHICH IS AN UNPRECEDENTED BUILD
OUT AS I SAID, BUT WE ARE MAKING
STRIDES TOWARDS THAT. SO
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS MORE
THAN 8500 MEGAWATTS OF BETTER
ENERGY STORAGE ONLINE. THAT'S
ENOUGH ELECTRICITY TO POWER 8.5
MILLION HOMES FOR UP TO FOUR
HOURS AND THEN IN A RECENT
MIDTERM ULA BY RELIABILITY
REPORT, THE CPUC PER HAD
PREDICTED THAT WE WOULD REACH
10,000 MAKE LOTS OF BATTERY
STORAGE BY 2026. BUT NOW WE'RE
SEEING NUMBERS THAT ARE SHOWING
WE MAY REACH 10,000 MEGAWATTS IN
THE FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR AND
HEARD THE CHAIRS SAY THE OTHER
DAY, POSSIBLY EVEN IN MARCH. SO
IT IS, YOU KNOW, MOVING FAST,
AND I AM NOT STEEPED IN ENERGY
STORAGE. AND YOU KNOW I'M NOT
THE LEAD ON WORKING ON THAT AREA
EITHER, BUT I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED BY THESE NUMBERS. AND
YOU KNOW, LITHIUM VALLEY WILL
PLAY A ROLE IN THAT. BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THAT DOMESTIC SOURCE OF
LITHIUM. SO I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT PIECE AND THEN ALSO
THE OPTION CERTIFICATION AGAIN
DOES ENABLE THAT PATHWAY FOR, UM
YOU KNOW, ASSEMBLY OR
MANUFACTURING OF BATTERIES TO
COME THROUGH, UM, IN TERMS OF
PERMITTING THROUGH THAT PROCESS,
SO THERE ARE AREAS WHERE YOU
KNOW IT'S CONNECTING, AND SO
SEEING THESE NUMBERS, AND THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING IS REALLY
EXCITING. THANK YOU. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. AND
AH! I DID NOT HAVE THE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT FROM MY FAMILY. WHEN I
WENT TO THE COMPANY WANT TO
SALUTE ALL OF THEM BEING IT
HELPS TO BE MEXICAN. WE TEND
COME IN BIG GROUPS. THANK YOU.
THIS HAS BEEN ENJOYABLE, AND
WE'VE TAKEN A LOT OF YOUR TIME
AND ASK A LOT OF QUESTIONS. I
JUST HAVE ONE MORE. YOU'RE THE
LEAD COMMISSIONER ON AUDITS SO I
WOULD ASK YOU MAYBE TO, UM, SAY
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR APPROACH
ON OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS
AND PARTICULARLY HOW FUNDS USED
BY THOSE IMPLEMENTED THOSE
IMPLEMENTED BY THIRD PARTY
ENTITIES, IF YOU JUST WANT TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF DESCRIPTION
OF YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON THAT
FOR US YEAH, SO FORTUNATELY, I'M
LEARNING THE AUDIT PROCESS WE
HAVE. AND AS THE LAWYER
ATTORNEY, THAT'S ONE OF MY
DUTIES. EXCUSE ME, THE LAWYER
TURNING THE ATTORNEY
COMMISSIONER, AND, UH, WHAT WERE
WE HAVE AN AUDITOR WHOSE EXPERT
HAS EXPERIENCED SHE'S NEW TO THE
COMMISSION. BUT SHE'S DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB MOVING ON THAT
FRONT. WE'RE KIND OF LEARNING
TOGETHER, BUT WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TAKE REQUESTS FROM
INTERNALLY FROM OUR DIVISIONS
WHEN THEY DO WANT TO GATHER MORE
INFORMATION ON WHETHER THEY'RE
YOU KNOW, SEEING A PROBLEM WITH
THE THIRD PARTY IN SO THAT
THEY'RE GIVEN A GRANT TO AND
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE PROCESSES ARE IN PLACE THAT
ARE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THEY
SPEND THE MONEY WISELY AND ON
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE, SO
IT'S REALLY HELPFUL TO HAVE THE
AUDIT PROCESS. YOU KNOW, AT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION SO THAT WE CAN
DO THAT WE CAN CHECK ON THE
THIRD PARTIES. UM I'M NOT SURE
IF I'M ABLE TO DISCLOSE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES, BUT, UM, YOU KNOW, IF
AGAIN IT'S REALLY HELPFUL WITH
GRANTS, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WE YOU
KNOW, DO GIVE MAJOR GRANTS, AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MONEY THAT WE ARE INVESTING IS
BEING APPLIED WISELY THAT IT'S
LEADING TO THE TYPES OF OUTCOMES
THAT WE WANT FOR COMMUNITIES AND
FOR THE STATE. AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. SO THE CHAIR AND I
ARE THE COMMITTEE OF, UM, IN
TERMS OF THE AUDIT COMMITTEE,
AND THEN WE HAVE STAFF WHO ARE
WORKING WITH US. SO WHO HAVE
BEEN ON HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING THE
COMMITTEE FOR A WHILE SO THAT
IT'S ALSO HELPFUL TO HAVE THEM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO SPOT
ISSUES THAT SHOULD BE COMING
THROUGH THE AUDIT COMMITTEE. AND
THEN IF WE'RE CURIOUS ON
SOMETHING, FOR EXAMPLE, UM, THE
RELIABILITY OF TV CHARGERS THAT
THE ENERGY QUESTION HAS INVESTED
IN, FOR EXAMPLE, THAT CAME UP AS
A QUESTION, AND WE WANTED TO
CHECK IN ON THAT. SO THOSE ARE
THE TYPES OF THINGS WE CAN DO
THROUGH THE AUDIT COMMITTEE. I
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION, SENATOR
ATKINS, BUT EXCUSE ME. I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT. UM. YES UM, I THINK
YOU KNOW, I'VE SERVED ON AN
AUDIT COMMITTEE WHEN I WAS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. IT WAS WE
STARTED TO FORM AUDIT COMMITTEES
AND REALIZED HOW IMPORTANT IT
WAS FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
TAKE THAT ROLE, BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY AT THAT LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT ANYWAY, WE WERE THE,
UM, FISCAL FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
UM. YOU GAVE AN EXAMPLE OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT AN E V CHARGING,
I MEAN, SINCE YOU'VE BEEN THERE
AND SINCE JANUARY OF LAST YEAR.
YOU'VE HAD EXAMPLES OF WHERE
YOU'VE HAD QUESTIONS. I KNOW YOU
CAN'T GIVE SPECIFICS, BUT YOU IN
THAT FUNCTION AS AN AUDIT
COMMITTEE. YOU'VE HAD QUESTIONS
WHERE YOU'VE BROUGHT THE STAFF
IN TO SAY WE HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS. THERE ARE CONCERNS
THE PROCESS YOU FEEL REALLY
WORKS, AND THERE IS GOOD
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ABSOLUTELY AND SO IT CAN WORK
BOTH WAYS WHERE YOU KNOW STAFF
IN THE DIVISIONS. IF THERE WE
HAVE PROJECT MANAGERS WHO ARE
RECEIVING GRANTS, PROJECTS THAT
ARE IN THE CAN BRING THE ISSUES
TO US. AND SO THEY CAN SAY, YOU
KNOW, WE WOULD LIKE TO
PRIORITIZE THIS AUDIT BECAUSE WE
ARE SEEING, YOU KNOW, SUBTYPE OF
URGENCY AND SO WE'LL TALK ABOUT
IT IN THE COMMITTEE AND
DETERMINE WHAT THE TIMING SHOULD
BE. AH, SO IT IS. I AGREE WITH
YOU VERY HELPFUL TO HAVE THAT
INTERNAL PROCESS THAT WE CAN
RELY ON TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE BEING A HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO OURSELVES ON
MAKING SURE THAT THE MONEY THAT
YOU KNOW WE ARE TRUSTED WITH IS
BEING SPENT CORRECTLY AND WE'LL
DELIVER RESULTS, AND IF IT'S
NOT, THEN WE TAKE ACTION AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT TO
DO. THANK YOU. THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL. UM OKAY. UH, I THINK
NOW WE CAN GO TO THE PUBLIC. SO
LET ME ASK MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT TO FAMILY MEMBERS. SPEAK
FOR OKAY. GOOD SUGGESTION. UH
THANK YOU FOR THAT SUGGESTION.
UH I'M SORRY, MADAM PROTEIN.
HE'S I'M JUST REMINDING
EVERYBODY HE'S JUST FILLING IN
TODAY. OKAY WE WILL LET PEOPLE
SPEAK. I WILL ASK, GIVEN THE
LONG LINE THAT SEEMS TO BE
FORMING TO DO THAT. I WILL ASK
FOR YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
IF OUR TITLE OF ANY, UM AND
THEN, UM, VERY BRIEF COMMENTS
WELCOME. DANIEL BLASTED HIDDEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. WE
REPRESENT THE PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITIES THAT SERVE
ABOUT 25% OF THE OF CALIFORNIANS
, AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT COMMISSIONER GALLARDO
HAS DONE, ESPECIALLY WITH
GEOTHERMAL DEVELOPMENT AND IN
THE LITHIUM VALLEY, AND SO WE
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE GOOD WORK YOU'VE
DONE. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS
NICKEL MOLINA ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
AND APPOINTMENT OF NO. I MEAN
GALLARDO, UH, TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WELCOME HELLO. MY NAME
IS MARISSA AT VALETTA,
REGULATORY DIRECTOR FOR ECUADOR.
ATLAS WIND AFTER WHEN PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA. ECUADOR. THANKS THE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY AND
SUPPORT OF NOEMI GALLARDO.
ECUADOR APPRECIATE APPRECIATES.
COMMISSIONER GARY IS DEDICATION.
PUBLIC SERVICE IN HER PRIOR WORK
AT THE BEFORE BEING APPOINTED
COMMISSIONER. SHE HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT AND ACTIVE LEADER ON
CLEAN AND CLEAN ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT COMMISSIONER
GALLARDO AND ASK FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION OF HER APPOINTMENT
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALEJANDRO SOLIS,
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AS SOON AS
STRATEGIES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN. AND ALSO
THE GROUPS FROM LITHIUM VALLEY
COMMITTED ADVICE AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON, RICHELLE
MASON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT,
ALSO WANTED TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR THE CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE
FOR UNITED AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY OR CAUSE COMMUNITY FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT, LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
AND THE CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ACTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION, AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BERNADETTE DEL CHARRO,
WHO WAS PLANNING ON COMING IN
PERSON, BUT HAS A COLD AND IN IN
CONSIDERATION OF ALL OF US
STAYED HOME AND SEND ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI THERE.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON WORLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SEARLES VALLEY
MINERALS. ENERGY SOURCE.
MINERALS MP MATERIALS BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY,
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, SCALE MICRO GRID
SOLUTIONS AND EDP RENEWABLES ALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LILLIAN MERVIS WITH
EMC, CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR. WE
HAD A LOT WE WANTED TO SAY, BUT
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME WE REALLY
VALUE COMMISSIONER GUARDO'S
VALUES, DIFFERENT LEADERSHIP AND
ARE REALLY EXCITED TO WORK WITH.
YOU GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JUST FOR
THE RECORD, SENATOR WILK. NOT
ONE MEMBER HAS BEEN FROM HER
FAMILY YET. I'M JUST THAT'S WHAT
YOU KNOW. I'M PAYING ATTENTION.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON, ADAM
KHADAFI HERE ON BEHALF OF
GENERIC AND MORE SPECIFICALLY
OUR VICE PRESIDENT OF POLICY AND
HOSKINS, WHO SUBMITTED A LETTER
SUPPORTING THE CONFIRMATION
WORKED WITH COMMISSIONER GERARDO
AT SUNRUN AND APPRECIATE HER
DEDICATION TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
EQUITY HERE TO REGISTER OUR
SUPPORT FOR A CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO. THIS IS SANDY MALHOTRA,
THE FOUNDER AND CEO FOR LITHIUM
ION BATTERY COMPANY. ALL OF THAT
YOU GUYS WERE TALKING ABOUT JUST
TAKE 10 SECONDS BECAUSE WE ARE
HERE. ONLY BECAUSE OF
COMMISSIONER GUARDO. SO WE'RE
SETTING UP WHAT WILL POSSIBLY BE
THE LARGEST CATHODE MATERIAL OR
BATTERY MATERIALS. FACTORY IN
THE UNITED STATES OUTSIDE OF
CHINA. NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE IN
RANCHO CORDOVA. AND WE HAVE
SECURED $770 MILLION LOAN FROM
THE DELAYS LOAN PROGRAM OFFICE.
550 IS COMING TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK YOU SEE,
EC WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN
BRINGING US HERE FROM TENNESSEE.
SO LIFE WAS GOING VERY GOOD
UNTIL LIMIT COMMISSIONER. SHE
SAID THAT YOU HAVE TO THINK BIG
WORLD WAS BIG. SHE TOOK US TO
LITHIUM VALLEY. SHE TOOK US TO
SALT AND SEA AND SPARKS IS VERY
PROUD AND VERY HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE ARE THE FIRST LITHIUM
BATTERY COMPANY TO PARTNER WITH.
AMERICAN INDIAN TRIBE TOURIST
MARTINUS. AND FOLKS, WE'RE
SETTING UP WHAT WE'RE SETTING UP
HERE IN LARGE LICCARDO OVER
HERE, REPEATING THAT DOWN IN
SALTON SEA. AND THAT'S BASICALLY
AN INVESTMENT OF $1.5 BILLION BY
SPARKS INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, CREATING 1500 JOBS
ALL THANKS TO HER, AND I THINK
YOU ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT
HIRING FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AGAIN TAX TO
COMMISSIONER GALLARDO AND TO HER
OFFICE TO ERIC STOKES. THEY MADE
IT VERY IMPORTANT FOR US. THAT
WE NEED TO HIRE AS MANY FOLKS
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SO. ALONG WITH JUST AS 40
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S INITIATIVE WE
HAVE COMMITTED TO HIRING 50% AT
LEAST 50% FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THANKS A LOT AND
TAURUS MARTINUS AND SPARKS IS
VERY, VERY, VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
COMMISSIONER GUARDO'S NOMINATION
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. VERY HELPFUL TO KNOW AND TO
HEAR. THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM PRO TEM MANDY
LEE ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN POWER
ALLIANCE. WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF COMMISSIONER GATORS JR GARDAS
REAPPOINTMENT. I APOLOGIZE. IT'S
LATE IN THE DAY. WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMISSIONER ON THE GROUND AND
SHE'S COMMUNITY ROOTED, AND, UM
COMMITTED TO ENERGY EQUITY,
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND E
J COMMUNITIES HAVE ALSO HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MISS
GALLARDO AND SOME OF HER
PREVIOUS ROLES BEFORE AND CAN
ATTEST TO HER TENACITY. UM AND,
UH, FULLY SUPPORT HER
REAPPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE ALEX MORRIS, THE
GENERAL MANAGER WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY POWER. WE ARE JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY, BACKED BY NINE
DÍAS AND WENT TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR YOU,
COMMISSIONER GUARDO WITH WHOM
I'VE WORKED FOR A DECADE IN MANY
DIFFERENT ROLES, AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
HARD WORK AND ETHICS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WEEK
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS, ANTHONY
SAMPSON ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE APPOINTMENT OF COMMISSIONERS
GALLARDO, LIKE MANY CAME HERE
WITH A LOT TO SAY, AS REQUESTED
BY SCAPA, BUT IN THE INTEREST OF
BREVITY, I KNOW HOW MUCH THEIR
LEADERS ARE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH THEM TO
DATE. SPECIFICALLY ON THE ISSUE
OF IMPLEMENTATION. SB 100, THE
LIKE, AND SO THEY'VE VERY, VERY
MUCH ARE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
CONFIRMATION HERE, AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE DIDN'T MEAN TO
SCARE THAT WILL. SENATOR WILK
DIDN'T MEAN TO SCARE THE FAMILY
AWAY FROM SPEAKING. BUT I ASSUME
YOU'RE HERE IN SUPPORT, AND
THAT'S THAT'S YOUR STATEMENT.
YOUR VISIBILITY ONE FINAL TIME.
YEAH WE WILL. WELL FIRST, I GOT
TO GO TO PEOPLE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION AND HOPE THAT NONE OF
THE FAMILY COMES UP, RIGHT? SO
LET ME LET ME AND MY ROLE IS IN
MY SERIOUS ROLE AS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE ASKED IF THERE IS
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CONGRATULATIONS NO ONE
FROM YOUR FAMILY STOOD UP. UM I
WILL COME BACK TO MY COMMITTEE
TO SEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
THE MOTION MADAM VICE CHAIR. HAS
MADE THE MOTION MADAM SECRETARY,
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
DÍAS SMALLWOOD CUEVAS SMALLER,
CLEAR THIS. I WILL CRY. I GROVE
GROVE. I ATKINS BY 5 TO 5 TO 0
AND I SHOULD HAVE SAID YES, YOU
CAN. THANK YOU, YEAH. UM YEAH. I
SHOULD HAVE SAID THIS AND I'LL
HAVE THE STAFF CONTACT
COMMISSIONER SIN WE WILL MOVE
THIS TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
FINAL CONFIRMATION TODAY IS THE
RECOMMENDATION TO OUR FULL
SENATE TO CONFIRM AND I DID NOT
SAY THAT PRIOR SO WE SHOULD DO
THAT. BUT WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS AND WE WILL MOVE
THIS ON TO THE FULL SENATE.
THANK YOU. I'M HONORED. THANK
YOU GRATEFUL. CONGRATULATIONS.
AH WE WILL OPEN THE ROLL ON ITEM
ONE A. AND THAT IS THE
CONFIRMATION AND WE WERE SORRY
YOU WEREN'T THERE, BUT I THINK
SHE FEELS CERTAIN THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE. MADAM
SECRETARY, WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL? GROWTH GROVE I FIVE TO 05
TO ZERO AND WE WILL LET HER KNOW
. I'M SURE SHE KNOWS FROM PAST
HISTORY, BUT JUST TO CONFIRM
WHAT OUR ACTION WAS TODAY TO
MOVE IT TO THE FULL SENATE. NO,
THAT WAS NOT YOU. THAT WAS ME
AND NOT, UM NOT LETTING HER
KNOW. OKAY, WE NOW NEED TO, UM,
ADJOURN INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM BEFORE US
THERE. WITH INCREDIBLE THANKS TO
EVERYBODY FOR YOUR PATIENTS
TODAY.